So Leute, soll ich euch mal, äh, was, äh, soll ich euch mal was, was, äh, wie, wie, wie soll ich sagen, was, ähm, was Erfreuliches berichten?
Und zwar das, was wir die letzten zwei Mal im Stream programmiert haben, funktioniert.
Der Coolchamp ist am Start.
Und ich hab's jetzt getestet mit dem zweiten Sensor.
Und, äh, das funktioniert.
Zweiter Sensor am Start.
DHL-Mann war schon vor ein paar Tagen da.
Aber ich hab jetzt zwei Sensoren dran und der erkennt automatisch die Sensoren und automatisch Licht und Temperatur und alles.
Und ich kann jetzt meinen Kühlschrank überwachen.
Äußerst nice.
Ja, wie gesagt, DHL war, DHL war vor zweiter, ne warte mal, warte mal, heute ist Samstag, Freitag.
Aber am Donnerstag war DHL da.
Wann war der erste?
Ja, am Donnerstag, am Donnerstag war DHL da.
Äh, gut, äh, es ist jetzt grad Ostern, hab ich nix mehr von gehört.
April Schätz von DHL, sie haben halt eine Lieferung zugestellt, ja.
Also kam ich mir echt vor.
Echt fail.
Spare 25% bei Microsoft Spring Sale.
Ihr könnt mich mal, ich wüsste gar nicht, was ich da kaufen sollt.
Ja, das, äh, macht nix.
Mod-Check, Mod-Check.
Wen haben wir sonst noch da?
Oma, Omas Drogen ist am Start.
Schon zwei Monate.
Kann ja gut so funktionieren.
Excellent.
Ba, ba, dings, ba, da, bum, zehn Monate.
Das ist ja ganz knapp vor Hyper-Subscription.
Meinung zu Gaming-Boostern.
Ich persönlich denke, das ist eher der psychologische Effekt.
Wenn überhaupt, also, ich hab meine Zweifel, dass man dadurch wirklich besser spielt.
Man wird vielleicht ein bisschen hibbeliger, aber gerade an Energy-Drinks und generell Koffein,
da gewöhnst du dich ja auch relativ schnell und bist dann eher merkwürdig drauf, wenn du mal keins hast.
Aber für mich ist das nix, weil ich trink auch keinen Kaffee und sowas.
Das Abgedrehteste, was Gaming-Booster abgeht, was ich bisher gesehen hab,
war E-Mail.
Das ist ja immer noch das hier, das ist ne Pille.
Also nicht nehmen, ja, aber ich fand das Produkt nur witzig.
Das ist ne Pille, die kannst du dir einschmeißen, wie Omas Drogen hier im Chat gerade.
Weiß ja nicht, was die Oma so nimmt.
Und dann bist du viel geiler danach, ja.
Und vor allem, dass es irgendwelche Pillen sind.
Wenn die dich damit erwischen, denken sie erstmal wunderbar, was das ist.
Und die sagen auch nicht nur, dass sie Gaming-Boosten sontern,
sondern dass sie gegen, ähm, dass sie gut sind für Memory und Brain.
Für die Augen.
Du siehst dann besser.
Für bessere, bessere, bessere Kacke.
Wobei ich glaub, die meinen damit eher, dass die, dass die, dass die besser abbaubar sind.
Also das ist Schwachsinn.
Das ist Schwachsinn.
Und am besten war doch, wo sie geschrieben haben, hilft gegen, ich wusste bis dahin, dass das Wort, gar nicht, dass das Wort existiert.
Hilft gegen Mental.
Mental Fock.
Also, also, vernebelt, vernebelte Wahrnehmung, ja.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das, dass das gibt.
Ich mach mal die VM an und dann mach ich die ganzen Kram mal zu.
Weil ihr wisst ja, auf AliExpress gehe ich am liebsten aus der VM.
Ich kann dazu lustigerweise gar nicht viel sagen.
Ich glaube, KNX ist eine richtig nice Geschichte, wenn du halt was hast, wo du das Haus baust.
Im Hinblick dessen, also schon in dem Hinblick, dass du sowas haben willst.
Also, ich glaube, das ist eine richtig nice Geschichte, wenn du halt was hast, wo du das Haus baust.
Also, wenn du überall Kabel hast und sowas.
Da ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt und auch eine Überlegung wert.
Du kannst, du kannst KNX mit einem Raspberry Pi machen.
Du kannst es über Home Assistant ansteuern und so.
Das ist, das ist schon wohl relativ offen.
Weiß ich, die Hardware ist wahrscheinlich relativ teuer.
Ich hab mich damit aber nie großartig beschäftigt, weil mir schlicht und ergreifend die Leitungen fehlen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ja, würd ich auch so machen.
Wenn ich Scheiß baue, sag ich, das war Mental Fock.
Genau, das ist die beste, beste Begründung überhaupt.
Ähm.
Äh, übrigens, die beste Begründung auf der Arbeit ist, wenn du was vergessen hast, du sagst, Leute, es ist, es ist erstaunlich, wie gut das funktioniert, ne.
Äh, wenn du, wenn du hier auf der Arbeit richtig Hackerman machst und du vergisst irgendwas oder, äh, das funktioniert nicht so, wie es ist.
Und am Ende kommt dann, kommt dann einer und sagt, Max, das, was du gemacht hast, geht nicht richtig.
Und dann, dann muss man ihn fragen, ja, okay, was meinst du, was, was geht nicht so genau?
Und dann sagt er ja hier, guck mal, Funktionen, Funktionen, diese Funktion ist gar nicht drinne.
Und dann muss man einfach als Antwort sagen, wo steht das denn?
Das war nicht im Scope.
Nicht im Scope ist eines der besten Ausreden aller Zeiten.
Das, das, das, das, ihr könnt was sagen und es irritiert erst mal.
Einfach zu allem sagen, das war nicht im Scope.
Und wenn er was Gegenteil behaupten will, dann muss er dann irgendwelche, äh, falls es überhaupt sowas existiert, irgendwelche Meetingprotokolle und Sachen sich angucken, wo besprochen wurde, was angeblich im Scope.
Einfach sagen, nicht im Scope.
Einfach sagen, nicht im Scope und dann seid ihr zu 99% raus.
Diese Ausrede funktioniert nicht bei Inscope21.
Ja gut, der hat andere Probleme, glaube ich.
Denen interessiert es ja, ob der nicht im Scope ist.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich sowas in der Richtung, ja.
Übrigens auch eine super, auch eine super Ausrede, wenn man auf der Arbeit am Start ist.
Und ich mach den ganzen Kreml mal kurz zu.
Wop, alles klar.
Ach, guck mal.
Der Baumhof Fund ist immer noch am Start.
Ich starte mal neu, mal gucken, was es heute für ein Hintergrundbild gibt.
Ich muss dazu übrigens gar nicht neu starten, fällt mir ein.
Ich muss einfach das Skript ausführen.
Tja, äh, aber Reboot.
Aber Hauptsache, Hauptsache mal Reboot.
Will C-Matrix für Windows, bester Anwendungszweck für WSL.
Äh, auch eine super, auch eine super Ausrede.
Oh, nicht Mac.
Nicht Mac.
Vertippt.
Fast.
Was auch eine super Ausrede ist.
Also, auf der Arbeit jetzt.
Wenn einer, wenn einer fragt, habt ihr...
Okay, heute ist irgendein Leuchtturm als Hintergrundbild.
Wenn euch auf der Arbeit einer fragt, so nach dem Motto, und wie sieht's damit aus?
Bist du schon, bist du schon, äh, vorwärts gekommen?
Das ist ja auch so eine, so eine, so eine Stonksfrage.
Und geht's voran, so, ähm, wie ist denn hier der Status und solche Dinger?
Dann ist die ultimative Antwort, da sind wir dran.
Einfach, einfach auf alles, wo ihr gar nicht wisst.
Was der Typ wollt.
Oder, äh, wo ihr es vergessen habt.
Einfach sagen, da sind wir gerade dran.
Und wenn er, wenn er noch hartnäckiger ist.
Und wenn er noch hartnäckiger ist.
Könnt ihr sagen, ihr seid mit, wir sind da mit Hochdruck dran.
Aber wir sind da dran.
Reicht den meisten Leuten schon, um zu sagen, naja gut, ach, wenn, ach, wenn ihr dran seid.
Dann, dann ist, dann ist da gar kein Problem.
Dann, dann macht mal, macht mal schön.
Ja, ja, da sind wir dran.
Probiert das mal aus, ey, ohne Scheiß.
Es ist unglaublich, wie oft das klappt.
So, also.
Warum habe ich hier eigentlich so viele Fenster auf?
Wir hatten früher, äh, dort wo ich, äh, bei dem Provider, wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe, ne.
Da hatten sie einen, äh, First Level Support.
Der halt, der halt echt gar keinen Plan hat.
Das waren drei Mädels.
Und, ähm, die wurden halt auch nicht dafür eingekauft, Plan zu haben.
Die wurden, die wurden dafür eingekauft, dass sie sich am Telefon nett anhören.
Dass die Leute sich nicht so aufregen.
Eigentlich, eigentlich eine richtige Eck, Big Brain Entscheidung, ne.
Und, ähm, die, den ihr Job war, im Prinzip, sich nett anzuhören am Telefon.
Und die haben immer so eine Standard-Mail geschickt, wenn sich einer beschwert hat.
Und da stand auch, auch drin, ähm, dass der Techniker mit Hochdruck an der Entstörung arbeitet.
Es war immer die gleiche Mail.
Vollkommen egal, ob der Techniker wirklich dran gearbeitet oder nicht.
Die haben einfach immer die gleiche Mail geschickt, dass der Techniker mit Hochdruck dran arbeitet.
Und das hat geklappt.
Die meisten Leute waren zufrieden.
Entstört.
Störung ist auch so ein richtiges Kackwort, ja.
Naja, bei der Telekom, oder gerade bei Vodafone, ist ja quasi Störung der Normalfall in manchen Bereichen.
Weißt du, warum ich das mach?
Das war auf Aufruhrzeichen 1.
Ach, ich bin ja nicht eingeloggt.
Da hab ich erklärt, warum ich das mach.
Das hab ich mir irgendwann mal angewöhnt und jetzt krieg ich's nicht mehr los.
Ich will, ich will, ich will's auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht loskriegen.
Ich find das, ich find das, das ist nix, was mich jetzt, äh, belastet, ja.
So, machen wir mal kurz die Grenzen.
Also, ich hab's zwar in Titel geschrieben, China, aber wir werden wahrscheinlich auch einiges bei Amazon kaufen.
Aber jetzt, nachdem das Schiff weg ist, kann es durchaus sein, dass wir wieder was in China bestellen.
Wo kommt man eigentlich die Störung bei Vodafone in letzter Zeit her?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, weil ich arbeite nicht bei Vodafone und man kriegt das, ich mach mal Werbung von AliExpress immer ganz schnell zu,
äh, man kriegt das ja nicht so mit.
Also, pff, ich, ich weiß es nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Pff.
Dann haben wir hier Banggood, haben wir Darkreader aus, ja, mit Darkreader sieht's so gut aus.
Man muss ja einmal, wisst ihr, was mich bei diesen China-Seiten, die H-Gate ist auch so ein Ding,
wisst ihr, was mich bei diesen China-Seiten immer hardcore verwirrt?
Ich glaube, ich hab das schon fünfmal gesagt.
Die Seiten sehen einfach fucking gleich aus.
Gibt es irgendwie das Ministerium für Webdesign in China, die alle, die alle China, China-Chinesen-Shops machen?
Guckt euch mal die Seiten an.
Das sind unterschiedliche Läden.
Ich glaube, die sehen alle gleich aus, mehr oder weniger.
Also, ich mein, die Ähnlichkeit ist nicht zu leugnen, oder?
Warum, warum krieg ich Mädels ohne Wäsche empfohlen?
Flash-Deals.
Moment, ist, ist es Flash-Deals, weil die am flashen ist, oder, oder weil es so schnell vorbeigeht?
Wo, Katos?
By the way, kein Photoshop-Bild wieder, null, ja.
Ha, könnt ihr euch noch an das Bild erinnern?
Wo der Bauch nicht richtig auf das, auf die Hose gepasst hat, bei dem einen AliExpress-Bild.
Da hatten wir doch mal ein Bild, da wurden auch, da wurde auch Unterwäsche gezeigt, und der Bauch hat überhaupt nicht zur Hose gepasst.
Das war zu, das war richtig schlecht zu sagen, Photoshopt.
Nein, die sind nicht alle Alibaba, das sind unterschiedliche, äh, das sind unterschiedliche Sachen, und es gibt, es gibt ja noch mehr China-Shops, aber die sehen alle gleich aus.
Die haben, als hätten die, als hätten die einen offiziellen Staats-Webdesigner.
Oder so, oder wie auch, äh, was auch immer die, die Chinesen da so haben, und der macht einfach für alle Shops die Webseiten.
Wie, we use cookies, als würde euch das in China interessieren, das ist, okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Datenschutz-Disclaimer bei Banggood, was steht da so drin?
Seite nicht gefunden, oder was?
Okay, Standardtext.
Thanks for submitting feedback.
Äh, ich hab kein Feedback.
Und ich glaube, das geht einfach schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Okay, wir informieren uns jetzt erstmal über Corona bei Banggood, was sonst?
Das ist jetzt die beste Stelle, ums...
FAQ, ah, okay.
Geht nicht so viel, oder?
Oh, doch.
Will my package have COVID?
Ja, ja, ganz bestimmt.
Ganz bestimmt.
Ganz bestimmt werden die Dinger desinfiziert, bevor sie es rausschicken.
Die, die, die...
Die Chinesen-Fabrik in Shenzhen, ähm, die desinfizieren mein Paket ganz bestimmt vorher.
Ja, ja, in China gibt's kein COVID, alles klar.
Das ist ja auch immer, das ist ja so die Sache, die Chinesen melden einfach keine Zahlen mehr und sagen dann, ja, wir haben nix mehr, es ist weg.
Wenn wir was hätten, ja, ihr seht's doch an den Zahlen, wir haben nix mehr.
So, also.
Das ist, das ist genau das gleiche wie da in...
CE-Zeichen drauf ist und sowas.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Wobei, das kann man, glaube ich, eh selbst draufdrucken.
CE gleich China-Export.
Ja.
Was ist das eigentlich für ne Pädobär-Werbung hier?
Für Mama und die Kleinen.
Die Kleinen kriegen ne Drohne, wo sie dann beim Nachbarn über den Zaun gucken können und Mama kriegt nen Kinderwagen, oder wie?
What?
Ähm.
Wahnsinn.
Also, gucken wir mal kurz.
Ich brauche nix wahnsinnig Dringendes, aber es gibt so ein paar Sachen, da wollte ich schon die ganze Zeit mal nachgucken, aber das können wir auch einfach im Stream machen.
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz schauen, wo ich mein Dokument hab.
Ah, hier.
Okay, wunderbar.
Leute, ich bin immer noch am überlegen, was ich mit meiner USV mache, ne.
Ich hab ja, ich hab ja seit ein paar Jahren so ne, so ne, äh, Cyberpower, so ein Teil hier, glaube.
Ne.
Irgendwie so ein Teil.
Rack Mount.
Ja, ich, so, so ein Teil hab ich ja seit zwei Jahren und die Batterie ist kaputt.
Mein komplettes Rack ist kaputt gegangen wegen der Batterie.
Ich bin immer noch am überlegen, soll ich einfach die USV komplett rauskicken und sagen...
Moment, und sagen, und sagen...
Piss dich, Aldo!
Oder soll ich die Batterie tauschen?
Ich bin da hin und her gerissen, weil...
Das Ding geht wieder kaputt in zwei Jahren und das ganze Rack geht aus.
Ja, ja, optimaler Produktname, wer kommt da nicht drauf?
C-P-O-R-600-E-R-M-1-U-Rack-Mount kommt da eigentlich noch dabei.
Hier, R-M-1-U, ja, alles klar.
Also ich, ich tendiere aktuell dazu, ich lass die im Rack einfach als Beschwerung unten drinnen und das war's.
Und ich, oder ich hol mir ne andere USV, die nicht kaputt geht, wenn die Batterie kaputt ist.
Weil ich soll, ich, ich würde ja eigentlich von der USV erwarten, dass wenn Strom da ist und die Batterie kaputt ist, dass es einfach weiter geht.
Das ist ja noch nicht mal ne Online-USV, wo alles durch die Batterie geht.
Dachte ich zumindest, ja.
Aber anscheinend doch.
Keine Ahnung.
Die haben, die, die Chinesen haben Corona besser unter Kontrolle als wir.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Die Chinesen haben ja prinzipiell da auch wenig Probleme mit, wenn es um Beschränkungen geht.
Im Zweifelsfall sagen die einfach, jeder, den wir auf der Straße erwischen, erwischen wird erschossen.
Easy.
Und dann geht keiner mehr raus.
Ich weiß nicht, ob, ich weiß nicht, wie, was sie wirklich machen, ja.
Aber die Chinesen haben da im Prinzip kein Problem damit.
Das ist das Geile.
Dieses Krankenhaus gebaut haben.
Ihr kennt ja dieses Bild.
Kennt ihr dieses Bild?
China Krankenhaus Bagger.
Dieses, genau.
Das da.
Das ist auch so ein richtig geiles Chinesen-Marketing-Bild.
Was genau machen diese Bagger da eigentlich?
Jetzt sagt mir nicht baggern.
Ich, ich bezweifle, dass man effektiv baggern kann.
Mit 50 Bagger.
Auf diesem Grundstück.
Zumal da gar keine Löcher sind so richtig.
Die haben einfach die Bagger für das Foto dahin, für das hinten, für das dahinten.
Du kannst da nicht, das geht doch gar nicht effektiv damit.
Da muss ein LKW hin, die Sachen abtransportieren und sonst was.
Kannste voll knicken.
Das ist einfach so ein Marketing-Bild von den Chinesen.
So nach dem Motto, nehmt man ein Feld, stellt 50 Bagger drauf und wir fotografieren das dann mit einer Drohne.
Was ist gelb und kann nicht schwimmen?
Oh, da gibt's einiges.
So ein DHL-Auto.
So ein DHL-Auto zum Beispiel.
Wo wir grad, wo wir grad bei absolut unwitzigen Witzen sind.
Was ist blau und steht am Kopierer?
Der Praktifant.
Haha, lul, Alter.
Es gibt so unglaublich viel unlustige Sachen.
Richtig Fence-Champ, Alter.
Richtig schlecht.
So, ähm, ja genau, das denk ich mir auch, Leonidas.
Weil...
Eigentlich ist es ne Offline-Uhr.
Und die sollte eigentlich weiter funktionieren, auch wenn die Batterie kaputt ist.
Mein Problem ist, ich finde dazu überhaupt keine Information.
Wenn er irgendwo stehen würde, so nach dem Motto, Batterie hält drei Jahre, aber solange
Strom da ist, bleibt das Rack weiterhin an, würd ich das Ding kaufen.
Am besten noch in Rack-Bauweise.
Gilt auch ohne.
Ich kann auch unten einfach nen Stein quasi in USV-Form reinlegen ins Rack, ist auch okay.
Wer bei Amazon kauft, schadet der deutschen Wirtschaft.
Juckt mich nicht.
Ich kauf da, wo es für mich am einfachsten ist.
Und außerdem kaufen wir in China.
Also wenn wir in China kaufen, schaden wir garantiert nicht der deutschen Wirtschaft.
Weil die Sachen, die wir da kaufen, die gibt's hier gar nicht.
Ja, also wie gesagt, dieses Bild ist halt ultra geil mit den Baggern hier, einfach random
rumbaggern.
So, und was ich sagen wollte bei den Chinesen, die haben halt da überhaupt keine Probleme
mit, ne.
Was, also ich frag mich halt ernsthaft, stellt euch mal vor, die Chinesen sind hier am Baggern,
wie verrückt.
Und der Oberbauminister hat gesagt, in 10 Tagen müsst ihr fertig sein, sonst werdet
ihr alle erschossen.
Keine Ahnung, was die so sagen, ja.
Stellt euch mal vor, da fällt einer vor den Bagger.
Jetzt frag ich mich, ziehen die den aus der Grube raus oder schütten die die Grube einfach
zu?
Weil's schneller geht.
Bin mir da nicht so sicher.
Wahrscheinlich wird der verbuddelt.
Und, ähm, dann kriegt die Familie noch irgendwie, irgendwie nen Brief, dass der Vater ehrenhaft
für, äh, für das Vaterland sein Leben gelassen hat und der Bagger rollt drüber oder so.
Bei Maxi in China immer jeder, okay, vielleicht wirst du auch geköpft oder so, wobei, nee,
geköpft ist eher, ist, ist nicht China, ich glaub, ich glaub, die Chinesen erschießen
die eher, Leute.
Geköpft wirst, glaub ich, eher so in, so im Nahen Osten irgendwo, ich glaub, die köpfen
noch ganz gerne, Leute.
Aber zumindest.
Eine Sache sieht man ganz gut an China, ähm, die haben es mit Menschenrechten nicht so
und ich weiß, ich bring den Chalk jetzt zum 50.000.
Mal, aber deswegen ist Java und C++ auch so beliebt in China.
Guckt euch Github-Repos an, ganz viel aus China ist Java oder C++, das wundert mich
einfach nicht mehr bei den Chinesen.
Ja, nur dass die Franzosen, die Franzosen das nicht mehr machen.
Also so viel, so viel glückliche Grills beim Shoppen bei DH, DH-Gate.
ByteStrike.
Wie?
Haben die, haben die mittlerweile, sind die noch nicht mal in der Lage mehr, äh, die
Leute irgendwie ordentlich zu köpfen, oder was?
Früher, das ist auch nicht mehr das, was es mal war, äh, das Shit-Repo, ja.
So, ähm, das stimmt überhaupt nicht vor 40 Jahren, Leute.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Was?
Chat, das ist, das ist verkehrt.
Die, die Franzosen.
Ja.
Die Franzosen, die letzte, das, das weiß ich zufällig, weil da hab ich mal einen Artikel
drüber gelesen, jetzt mal hier, sinnloser Knowledge-Drop, die letzte Hinrichtung in Frankreich
war ungefähr 1900 und da war Christopher Lee dabei, als Zuschauer, also, also Saruman
aus Herr der Ringe, ja.
Ich mein, welche anderen, ja, was weiß ich, welche anderen Länder da was, was machen,
aber in Frankreich war die letzte Hinrichtung 1900, das weiß ich, da hab ich mal einen
Artikel drüber gelesen.
Gelesen.
Wo es um Christopher Lee ging und Christopher Lee war quasi auf dem Weg in Urlaub oder so
und die sind dann durch Frankreich gefahren und haben da zugeguckt.
Würdest du Network, Network Equipment pre-flashed aus China kaufen, zum Beispiel Steckdosen
und Router?
Was denn so zum Beispiel?
Mir fällt gar kein Network Equipment ein, was ich aus China kaufen würde.
Ja, okay, dann, dann, dann ein bisschen später, nicht um 1900, aber ihr wisst, was ich mein.
Ja, also.
Ja, das, das, weiß nicht, inwieweit das zählt in Frankreich, weil in der hessischen Verfassung,
weiß ich, ob ihr das wisst, aber in der, in der hessischen, ich glaube, ich hab mich
übrigens ein bisschen verschätzt, ich glaube, es war nicht um 1900, es war wahrscheinlich
eher um 1900, 1930 oder so rum, aber in der hessischen, in der hessischen Verfassung gibt's
angeblich noch die Todesstrafe, aber halt, juckt halt kein.
Genau, genau.
Tatsächlich.
Guck mal hier, die Franzosen, die Franzosen 1977, hätt ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht bei
den Franzosen.
Ich hab gedacht, die sind da schon ein bisschen länger nicht mehr auf dem Trip, aber eins
muss man ja sagen, das haben die ja eh perfektioniert, die haben's ja quasi erfunden, so, so das,
das, das, das Köpfen im Endeffekt, also das, das Öffentlichkeitswirksame, ja, das wurde
vor ein paar Jahren aus der hessischen Verfassung entfernt, tatsächlich, ja, echt, ist es weg?
Ich, also, ich, ich wusste noch früher.
Ja.
In der Schule, da hat uns das mal ein Lehrer erzählt, dass, ähm, dass das in der hessischen
Verfassung noch drinsteht.
Aber gut, dann ist es erst letztens irgendwie rausgekommen.
Ja, ja, das stand ganz lange in der hessischen Verfassung drinne, aber gut, nachdem die hessische
Verfassung, wollt ich grad sagen, nachdem die hessische Verfassung in dem Fall eh nicht
interessiert, ist das egal, aber ist schon, äh, ist ein bisschen mittelalterlich, ne?
So, also.
Jetzt wollen wir mal anfangen einzukaufen.
Okay.
Ähm, ich hätte mal, ich hätte mal hier, an die Elektro-Stelzer bei uns im, an die Elektro-Pros,
ich habe im Flur ein, Moment, äh, Fahrstuhl, ich glaube, man sieht das sogar in einem Video,
Baustelle, Moment, Baustelle, da gibt's ein Video, da gibt's ein Video, auf der Baustelle
Real Life, ich glaube, das ist es.
Ich meine die Elektro-Champs, genau.
Ja, YouTube?
Ist das hier, wo ich mit dem Fahrstuhl fahre?
Nee.
Aber, ich glaube, hier sieht man's auch, also, na, okay, hier war doch im Haus gar nix, ähm,
warte mal, ich habe doch ein Video, wo ich den Fahrstuhl vor meinem Opa zeige.
So, und da sieht man das ganz gut, was ich euch fragen muss, weil ich habe so ein Leerrohr,
ja gut, was auch immer, anscheinend, anscheinend findet man's nicht, also ich habe ein Leerrohr
im Flur, und vielleicht sieht man das hier?
Ja.
Auf.
Hier.
Ja.
Warte mal.
Jetzt, wo ich rausgehe.
Magst du ein bisschen die Kamera rechts ge...
Ich hätte mal die Kamera ein bisschen schwenken können, das brauche ich jetzt sieben Jahre
später.
Also, hier habe ich ein Leerrohr in der Wand, so quasi hier dahinter, hier ist ein Leerrohr
in der Wand, und, ähm, du glaubst das zweite Video, das ist doch das zweite Video, ach,
Moment, Moment, ich habe doch das Bild mit den...
Genau!
Das Bild mit, mit den, mit den Bildern vom Opa, der so viele nackige Mädels gemalt hat.
Muss ich aufpassen, das kann ich jetzt hier im, im Stream nicht zeigen, ne?
Aber hier, wow, beste Kameraführung aller Zeiten.
So, hier neben, Leute, hier habe ich ein Leerrohr, hier, so, da wo, da wo es karteert, das Bild.
Hier habe ich ein Leerrohr, so, und das Leerrohr geht vom Keller, erster, äh, Erdgeschoss,
erster Stock, und ich würde gern im, im Flur, dort, wo das Leerrohr ist, jeweils noch Steckdosen
an die Wand machen, wobei es mussten gar keine Steckdosen an die Wand sein, halt Stecker.
Wie mache ich denn das am besten?
Also, ich will nicht am Verteilerschrank was machen, weil, da traue ich mich nicht, und
das soll gefälligst ein Elektriker machen.
Aber wie mache ich das am besten?
Also, ich würde einfach theoretisch unten im Keller, einfach in eine Steckdose ein Kabel
einstecken, und dann im Erd-, dann das Kabel, also erstmal natürlich nicht raus, äh, raus
machen, ähm, und dann einfach das Kabel, also, natürlich isoliert das Kabel kein offenes
Kabel, einfach das Kabel durch den Leerkanal schieben, raus machen im Erdgeschoss, hoch
schieben, raus machen im ersten Stock, dann dort einen Stecker dran machen.
Oder ne, oder ne, oder, oder so ne Buchse halt.
Und dann unten in den Stecker, in die Steckdose stecken.
Neben dem Rohr die Wand aufstemmen?
Nee, das will ich nicht machen.
Wann wird eigentlich mal wieder gestelzt?
Wir stelzen doch immer, was, was soll denn gestelzt werden?
Ja, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Gibt es denn, gibt es denn Steckdosen?
Nicht für die Wand, einfach so normale Steckdosen?
So, so welche, wo man einfach einen Kabel hat?
Welche, wo man einfach ein Kabel reinmacht, das ordentlich festmacht, dass es nicht rausgehen
kann?
Rei-, also wo man ein Kabel rein, reinschraubt?
Und, und dann hinten irgendwie ein bisschen Zugentlastung dran und auf, das muss noch
weder auf noch unter, das kann meinetwegen auch an der Wand baumeln, das ist mir egal.
Ich will da einfach einen Stecker, aber ich weiß nicht nach was ich suchen muss.
Das kann da auch raus baumeln aus der Wand, das ist mir egal.
Ich brauche einfach einen Stecker.
Der Chat weiß wieder Bescheid.
Ja, sowas im Endeffekt, genau, genau.
Sowas da, genau das, was der Chat gerade gepostet hat, sowas da.
Ah, erstmal schön hier, erstmal hier richtig schön Rafflings gespammt.
Excellent, excellent.
Sowas da in der Richtung, genau.
Wobei das halt echt ein bisschen Painschampig aussieht, oder?
Wie funsten das?
Da macht man hinten das Kabel rein.
Schraubts rein und machts nochmal extra fest, dass es nicht raus kann, oder?
AP-Gehäuse, Aufputzgehäuse mit Abdeckrahmen.
Aha, aha.
Der Chat, der Chat ist wieder richtig high-IQ.
Zeig mal hoch, zeig mal her.
Und wie soll das jetzt funktionieren?
Und wie macht man das, wie macht man das an die Wand?
Schrauben durch, oder klebt man das, oder?
Na, kleben kann ja schlecht sein, oder?
Wie macht man...
Schrauben sind so Drehlöcher.
Ah, ach so.
Also sprich, man macht Schrauben hin, hier durch dann quasi so.
Lass mal so ein bisschen rum.
Ach so, okay.
Ja gut, das ist eigentlich kein schlechter...
So, und ich würd's halt so machen, weil aktuell ist es halt...
Also normalerweise würde ich sagen, hier Elektriker, schließ mir das mal unten im Verteilerkasten an.
Und dann ist gut.
Aber aktuell ist es unglaublich schwierig, Elektriker-Termine zu machen.
Welche Elektriker-Termine zu bekommen.
Deswegen würde ich die Noob-Variante machen.
Einfach hier Steckdosen an die Wand.
Kabel nehmen, Kabel durch das Leerrohr schieben und unten einfach in die Steckdose stecken.
Ich habe unten im Keller noch genug freie Steckdosen.
Nehme ich einfach das Kabel, wenn es aus dem Kanal kommt, stecke ich es unten in die Steckdose rein.
Nee, nee, am Schaltschrank mache ich nichts, da habe ich zu viel Schiss vor.
Okay, das ist aber eine gute Idee, Chat.
Muss ich zugeben.
Da habt ihr mich mal auf eine Idee gebracht, das können wir machen.
Ja, also wenn schon, ich würde eh schon mal...
Am liebsten würde ich es aber ganz ohne Klemmen dazwischen machen, sondern, dass man das halt...
Und ich denke mal, das ist da auch so.
Wenn man das da reinsteckt, also ich denke mal, man wird das ziemlich fest machen können da drinnen, ne?
Wobei...
Ja gut, ich brauche da noch die passende Steckdose dazu, oder?
Also hier kommen ja die eigenen Steckdosen dann rein.
Ja?
Ja, also da braucht man gar keine Klemme.
Ich würde jetzt eine reinschrauben und wahrscheinlich schraubst du es fest und hinten hast du irgendwie so eine Art Zugentlastung dran und dann ist wahrscheinlich bombenfest das Ding.
Das könnte man machen, ja.
Gut, dass wir das geklärt haben.
By the way, ich habe vorhin auf Amazon gesehen...
Was war das?
Eine Steckdose mit...
Von K...
Nee, Moment.
Wie hieß der Hersteller?
Die angeblich flashbar ist.
Da habe ich mir überlegt, das müssten wir eigentlich gerade mal wieder ausprobieren.
Nein, irgendein Hersteller mit K am Anfang.
Alter, das ist alles der gleiche Crap.
Und ich habe schon eigentlich genug Steckdosen.
Das ist so ein Kokona-Ding.
Das ist was, das geht nur bei den Amis.
Das geht einfach mal wieder nur bei den Amis.
Schrauben...
Schneide mal ein Loch in die Wand.
Hahaha.
Mach das mal.
Viel Spaß.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass Nvidia PCI-Pass-Through für ihre Consumer-GPUs jetzt zulässt?
Du konntest Grafikkarten schon immer PCI-Pass-Through machen.
Ich habe sogar mal eine 9080Ti PCI-Pass-Through in Windows-KVM oder Linux.
Das ging die ganze Zeit schon.
Ach ja, stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Ich erinnere mich.
Ich glaube, man musste die...
Doch, ich weiß.
Doch, doch, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Das ging nicht so einfach.
Man musste...
Man musste die PCI-Express-ID irgendwie überschreiben oder sowas.
Genau.
Genau, genau.
Sowas muss man.
Du musstest irgendwie überschreiben, dass das nicht erkennt, dass du in KVM bist.
Aber es war easy.
Es war ein Config-Eintrag und es hat funktioniert.
Kein Ding.
Ja, das ist halt das typische Ami-Papp-Wand.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Also.
Eine 980Ti.
Keine 90...
80Ti.
980Ti.
So.
Also.
Gut, ihr habt mir schon mal geholfen mit den...
Meinst du die TP-Link-Steckdosen?
Nein.
Ich meine, irgendeinen Hersteller mit K.
Das habe ich vorhin, als ich auf dem Klo gesessen habe, auf dem Smartphone gesehen.
Moment.
Ich kann noch...
Ich gucke einfach mal kurz hier auf die Amazon-App.
Also.
Da steht doch immer History drin
Browser History
Übrigens Amazon empfiehlt mir gerade eine Wii
Hier
Previously viewed
Keksin
Keksin heißt der Hersteller
Keksin, Alter
So, und da
Habe ich in den Kommentaren gelesen
Man kann angeblich
Flaschen
Aber
Da stand
Habe ich nicht gesehen von
Hä
Kekwait
War das nicht die
Flash
What the fuck
Wie, wie kann man
Ah, hier
Flash
Hä, bin ich jetzt total hängen geblieben
Waren die das nicht
Ich habe
Ich habe vorhin
Auf dem Klo gesessen
Und habe bei Amazon die App mal aufgemacht
Habe Steckdosen empfohlen bekommen
Habe in die Kommentare geguckt
Und da stand drinnen
Irgendwie erfolgreich mit das Motor geflasht
Leonidas, da sind wir
Da wollte ich gerade danach gucken
Aber die sind es anscheinend nicht
Hm, sehr merkwürdig
Das muss die gewesen sein
Die ich mir angeguckt habe
Weil die war noch in der History
Also, vielleicht war das auch nicht die, die ich jetzt gefunden habe
Brain lag, richtig, brain lag
Ich habe ja glücklicherweise
Davon auch das Pack bekommen
Was man flashen konnte
Ich meine, man kann
Man kann die alle
Was zum Teufel machen die da
Was machen die Chinesen da schon wieder
Ich versuche gerade den Sinn zu erkennen
In dem was die Chinesen da treiben
Wieder
Die wollen glaube ich einfach nur zeigen
Wie geil das ist, dass ihre Steckdosen
So klein sind und da rein passen
Genau, die konnte man nämlich
Noch flashen, als ich die gekauft habe
Das geht mittlerweile
Nicht mehr so richtig
Ja, leider geht vieles nicht mehr
Vieles nicht mehr mit
Neue Firmware
Das Motor geht nicht
Ja, also man kann die Dinge aufschrauben
Man kann die Dinge aufschrauben
Und flashen, das haben wir ja auch schon im Stream gemacht
Ich habe da aber ehrlich gesagt
Moment, ich muss mal kurz Licht über den Home Assistant einschalten
Aber ich habe da ehrlich gesagt
Gar keinen Bock drauf
Die alle aufzuschrauben
Can't flash
There is no obvious way to open this
Klar, dazu für die Dinger
Gibt es sogar eine Anleitung
Im Internet, wie man die aufschraubt
Und flasht
Da wurde ich übrigens
Geflamed auf Twitter, weil ich geschrieben habe
Welcher Chinese hat sich das ausgedacht
Habe ich da geschrieben
Da wurde ich geflamed
Weil ich geschrieben habe
Das hätte sich ein Chinese ausgedacht
Oh, das geht ja gar nicht
Ich kann auch nicht
Einfach Assumen
Dass eine Steckdose aus China
Von einem Chinese gebaut wurde
Okay
Ich meine, vielleicht war es auch irgendein Brasilianer
Im Exil oder so
Ich würde halt einfach mal behaupten
Die Chance, dass es ein Chinese war
Sind relativ hoch
Weil es AliExpress Steckdosen sind
Country assumed
Ja, ja, die Leute
Haben mittlerweile echt einen kompletten Schaden
Was das Thema angeht
Richtig drin
Triggert, richtig triggert
Deine kann man nicht aufschrauben
Die sind gesteckt
Ja, ja, meine waren auch gesteckt
Und zwar ist die Plagg
Du hast hast du die hier
Das ist die, die ich eben bei Amazon gezeigt habe
Das sind die hier
Die sind nicht geschraubt
Die sind gesteckt
Aber es gibt eine Anleitung, wie du die flashen kannst
Danach habe ich das auch gemacht
Bei denen, wo das nicht über über WLAN ging
Du musst die aufhebeln?
Allerdings ist das echt
Ganz schönes Gefuddelbisse, die du aufhast
Du kannst die aufhebeln an der Seite
Ich hatte irgendwann keinen Bock mehr
Ich habe einfach einen kleinen Schraubenzieher genommen
Und habe den reingehauen mit einem Hammer auf der einen Seite
So ein Stück bis ich drunter war
Und dann habe ich es raus gehebelt
Das heißt alle, alle, alle Steckdosen
Also alle dieser Steckdosen, die ich jetzt geflasht habe
Die haben jetzt eine Beule an der Seite
Weil ich die auch...
Ja, weil ich die aufgemacht habe an der Stelle
Aber ich habe einfach Heißkleber oben ringsrum dann reingefüllt
Und wieder zugemacht
Scheiß drauf
Genau, und das Flashen ging folgendermaßen
Du, das sah exakt so aus, wie hier bei dem Typ auf dem Bild
Du musstest, du musstest hier dein Serial Input
Dein Serial Flasher musstest du anlöten
Ground und, glaube ich, GPIO 0 verbinden
Flasher dran
Und immer dran denken, wenn man den Flasher anschließt
Rx und Tx verteilen
Tauschen, also, ne?
Tx auf Rx und, und Rx auf Tx vom Flasher
Und funktioniert...
Aber schön ist es nicht
Was macht eigentlich Tuya Convert auf Github?
Gibt es da mittlerweile schon neue Sachen?
Hallo?
Was ist denn mit dem Darkreader los?
Warum ist der, warum ist der Darkreader so, so lahm?
Da müssen wir jetzt gerade mal kurz auf Shithub gucken
Ob es da irgendein...
Slow
Kann man es jetzt wieder einschalten?
Kann man es jetzt wieder einschalten, ohne dass wir hier blind werden?
Firefox
Äh
Slow
Confirmed on Firefox
Wie, warum ist das Closed?
Big Sur
Das ist das beste...
Also, ich finde...
Ich weiß nicht
Wie findet ihr Big Sur als Mac...
Äh...
Mac-O-Ls Name?
Die anderen fand ich cooler
Big Sur
Erinnert mich eher...
Äh...
Pfff...
Okay...
Ich...
Weiß gar nicht, woran mich das erinnert
Gefällt mir aber nicht gut
Warum schließen die das Ticket?
Das Ding ist...
Das Ding ist broken
Das Ding ist broken gerade
Genau
Github com itself freezing a lot Firefox
Die haben bestimmt doch heimlich an die Chinesen verkauft
Was für ein Ding?
Äh...
Nein, ich glaube nicht, dass Darkreader an die Chinesen verkauft ist
Ah, okay
Äh...
Hä?
Ah, guck mal, da ist er
Da ist er
Ah, guck mal, er hat sogar gepinnt
Okay, vielleicht gibt es bald eine neue Version, dass das ganze gefixt wird
Weil ohne Darkreader ist es auch doof, aber mit Darkreader, wenn die Seiten nicht laden,
es sackt auch richtig
Okay, es gibt eine neue Version, vielleicht unterstützen die ein bisschen mehr
ne...
Keine Chance, Leute
Man kann...
Man kann die Sachen nicht mehr ordentlich flashen mit der neueren Firmware
Das sackt
Man kann die nur noch aufschrauben
Was...
Was auf einen Schlag ganz viele China-Steckdosen komplett useless macht
Ich meine, dann kann ich mir auch direkt, dann kann ich mir auch direkt Shelly-Steckdosen kaufen, die kosten ein bisschen mehr, sowas hier zum Beispiel, kann ich mir auch direkt Shelly-Steckdosen kaufen, die kosten zwar mehr, aber die sind von Haus aus flashbar und kommen schon mit guter Firmware.
Hatten wir nicht letztens mal auf AliExpress geguckt, die Steckdosen, die mit Tasmota ausgeliefert werden, da wollte ich eh mal gucken.
Max, bitte sieh dir einfach die Go-Sund-SPL, gebatet, richtig gebatet, ja, hab ich doch, ähm, letztens, wir hatten das doch schon mal hier, die ersten für 34,84, das sind doch aber gar keine Go-Sund, oder?
I saw it, was hast du gesehen, was wurde geleakt, wieder, was wurde geleakt, hier kann eigentlich nichts geleakt werden.
Tasmota.
Tasmota, hier, also, naja, das ist von 2019, Tuya Convert funktioniert, 19.1., okay, excellent, excellent, okay, nice, nice, ja, Go-Sund sind sie erst nach Corona, Painschamp-Joke wieder.
Wie kann man Amazon auf Dark Mode umstellen mit einem Add-on? Aber der hat gerade Probleme, es ist ein wenig knifflig, die Platine sieht genauso aus wie Platinen.
Fotos von Blitzwolf, okay, der hat angelötet, mit Tuya Convert ging nicht, Tuya Convert funktioniert, 19.1., okay, Leute, ich bestell mir da mal testweise was, ich bestell mir einfach testweise was, guck, ob das geht, ihr wisst, ich bin ein, ich lass mich immer jebaiten von so einem Kram, ich hab davon genug, ich hab mehr als genug Steckdosen, ähm, ich brauch das eigentlich nicht.
Ah, das ist ein Vierer-Pack.
Das ist halt, das ist halt...
Das ist halt schon, guck mal, wenn ihr euch überlegt, so ein Shelly-Plug, so ein Shelly-Plug kostet, ähm, im Shop 16,58, das heißt, ich krieg hier für den Preis von zwei, krieg ich hier halt vier Stück.
Schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Funktion einwandfrei, okay.
Äh, wie oft hast du Probleme mit dem Zoll mit AliExpress? Gar nicht, weil die Chinesen das richtig machen, die Amis kriegen es immer nicht hin, beziehungsweise Zoll Leipzig kriegt es nicht hin.
Ähm, die Chinesen haben da kein Problem, die Chinesen schicken entweder über Spanien, Niederlande oder, oder sonst wie, oder direkt aus dem EU-Warenlager, die, die China-Dinger landen nicht im Zoll.
So, ähm, Tasmota, wie, wie hieß denn die, die, diese, die Firma, die vorgeflashte Tasmota-Steckdosen macht?
Ach so, übrigens, hier wollte ich noch vorhin was zu sagen.
Hast du schon gehört, dass Hessen, äh, dass Hessen kein Microsoft Teams mehr benutzen will?
Ja, das hab ich gehört.
Was ich ganz grausam finde ist, dass sie ihr eigenes Portal machen wollen.
Es ist ja nicht so, als gibt es nicht schon zigtausend VoIP und, und Chat-Sachen.
Max, was nutzt du für dein ganzes MQTT-Zeug?
Home Assistant.
Und den, den eingebauten Container, äh, MQTT-Container.
Ach, ja.
Ich probier das mal.
Ja, AliExpress, oder war das auf Banggood, wo es das gab?
Die Tasmota vor, pre-flashed.
AliExpress, Tasmota, pre-flashed.
Ah, da war es doch.
Pre-flashed.
Hier, da gab es die Dinger, pre-flashed Tasmota.
In China.
Vierer Pack, siehste, da kostet der Kram schon gleich mal mehr.
Ja.
Hat irgendjemand eine glorreiche Idee, warum ich nichts finde, wenn ich nach Tasmota suche bei AliExpress?
Obwohl, obwohl es hier im Titel drin steht.
Sind die Tasmota-Steckdosen einzeln im eigenen, oder können die sich?
Ne, Tasmota ist ja in der Regel meistens, äh, ein ESP-2866 oder eventuell ein ESP-32, das ist alles WLAN.
Also, ich bestell, Leute, ihr wisst, ich bin so.
Ich bin so ein Steckdosen-Flasher, ich flashe gerne Steckdosen.
Wenn der Chat sagt, ich, jetzt ist die große Frage, dem Chat vertrauen oder nicht.
Dem Chat vertrauen oder dem Chat nicht vertrauen, das ist jetzt die Frage.
Ich bestell die jetzt einfach und dann teste ich mal, ob das, ob das klappt.
Bam.
Chat lügt.
Moment, 34 Euro, haben die anderen nicht auch so viel gekostet?
Ne, die anderen haben 44 Euro gekostet, ne?
44.
Und Versand.
Bei Amazon kostet das kein Versand.
Angeblich kann man die noch flashen.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Hat jemand eine sinnvolle Erklärung dafür, warum die Chinesen überhaupt neue Firmware-Versionen benutzen, bei denen man das nicht mehr flashen kann?
Weil ich glaube, die, denen geht es doch einfach nur darum, viel zu verkaufen.
Denen kann es doch egal sein, ob die Leute die Sache flashen oder nicht.
Ich meine, das kaufen viele Leute einfach nicht mehr dann dadurch, ne?
Also ich kaufe mir die nicht, ich schicke die auch wieder zurück, weil man die nicht flashen kann.
Ich glaube eher, dass es nicht am Hersteller liegt, sondern an den, den, äh, Distributor-Leuten.
Die wollen, dass man ihren Scheiß verwendet und die Daten sammeln können.
Der Hersteller der Dinger selbst, denen ist das wahrscheinlich relativ egal.
Du hast eine GOSU und SP1, ja, aber nur einen Knopf statt den zwei USB-Ports.
Ja, mir geht's...
Ah, USB-Ports?
Achso, hier.
Du meinst, die da, du meinst, die haben, diese da haben bei dir keinen USB-Port, sondern nur einen Knopf?
Wie?
Da steht explizit USB dabei.
Wenn das kein USB hat, dann...
Das ist SP1, 1, 2, ja.
Ah, aber die haben keinen An- und Ausknopf.
Die lassen sich OTA flashen, okay, das ist nice.
Achso, das ist bloß nicht abgebildet, der Knopf.
Ne, es ist ja auch total uninteressant, die Steckdose mal so abzubilden,
dass sie sieht, ne.
Louis Vuitton hat auch was, was SP1, 1, 2 heißt.
Achtung!
GOSUND, Achtung!
Boah, ey, warum...
Ah, Painschamp, ich bin blind, Flashbang, Alter.
Oh, da gibt's verschiedene von.
Ah, das ist eine G-Bait-Seite, oder?
Ne.
Okay, das ist wie mal das Flash, das ist...
Will ich ja nicht, ich will jetzt über OTA flashen.
Hä?
Hier steht jetzt, dass die schon eine Weile nicht mehr OTA flashen.
Flashbar sind, what the fuck?
Wonka.
So, gibt's da von mal ein Bild?
Wie sieht der Schalter oben aus?
Sag mal, gibt es von dieser Steckdose einfach kein Bild von oben, wo der Schalter ist?
Ach, hier.
Ne, hier passt schon.
Aber es geht um Millimeter.
Bei Amazon schreiben sie in der Bewertung auch, dass das...
Hier schreiben manche...
Aber Moment, das ist das Falsche.
Hier schreiben die Leute nämlich, dass es angeblich...
...angeblich noch geht.
Januar 2021.
Ich glaube, es ist einfach ein bisschen Glück, was man noch flashen kann.
Und was nicht.
Das ist doch genau die gleiche.
Ne.
Das sind die ohne USB jetzt, oder wie?
Aber ich finde die mit USB viel geiler.
Leute, ich...
Wisst ihr was?
Scheiß drauf.
Bam.
Ich probiere das jetzt aus.
Und wenn nicht, machen wir im Stream auf und löten dran und flashen die.
Easy.
Oh, was habe ich hier alles noch im Basket drin?
What the f...
Ach so, vom letzten Mal.
Okay, kann ich alles wieder raus machen.
Habe ich...
Habe ich da alles schon?
Habe ich alles schon gekauft?
Habe ich alles schon?
Ich logge mich ja hier nicht ein und bestelle das.
Excellent.
Exquisite.
Okay.
Ist sehr schön.
Ich probiere das...
Wir probieren das im Stream aus, Leute.
Wir probieren das im Stream aus, ob sie es flashen lassen.
Und wenn nicht, wird auch...
Wird aufgeschraubt.
Ihr wisst, wie pfleglich ich Steckdosen behandle beim Aufschrauben.
Da wird dann rumgerobbt und sonst wie.
Und das letzte Mal hat mich die Steckdose ja massive jebaited mit hinten rum aufgebrochen
und dann festgestellt, vorne gibt es Schrauben für...
Ich DJ...
Jebaited.
Copper Miller...
Äh, Hiller.
Hiller.
Dankeschön für die zwei Monate Subs.
Excellent.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich keine Subs übersehen habe.
Tja, Amazon-Bewertungen lesen, Tasmota-Seiten gucken und hoffen.
So wirklich hundertprozentig ist da leider nix, ne?
Sonix hat Subscribed vor 41 Minuten.
Sorry, habe ich übersehen.
Zwei Monate.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Sonst habe ich nix übersehen.
Alles klar.
Excellent.
Für welches Anwendungsgebiet nutzt du WLAN-Steckdosen?
Äh, zum Beispiel, dass ich meinen 3D-Drucker ein- und ausschalten kann,
dass ich den Heizlüfter im Klo ein- und ausschalten kann,
dass ich...
den Staubsauger unten, wenn der am Aufladen ist,
automatisch ausschalten kann, wenn er voll ist.
Das ist übrigens ein cooles Einsatzgebiet für Steckdosen,
die, ähm, gucken können, was da gerade dranhängt.
Also, die so eine Verbrauchsanzeige haben.
Da kannst du nämlich einfach sagen, wenn...
Also, es ist ja meistens so, wenn Geräte aufladen,
die fangen ein bisschen langsam an, dann laden sie ein bisschen stärker
und am Ende geht's wieder runter.
Und ich hab gesagt, sobald das, was an der Steckdose dran ist,
unter 4 Watt...
ist, dann ausschalten.
Also, wenn das länger als 5 Minuten unter 4 Watt ist, dann ausschalten.
Weil, dann ist der Staubsauger vollgeladen.
Ja, für so Sachen verwende ich das.
Das ist äußerst praktisch.
Und ich kann das Ding, äh, auch noch aus dem Bett oder so ausschalten,
wenn ich sage, ah, Mist, hab ich vergessen.
Für alles mögliche, also...
Hast du Heizkörperthermostate im Einsatz?
Ja, hab ich.
Aber erst seit Neuestem.
Erst seit so...
Weiß nicht, 4, 5 Monaten.
Ich hatte am Anfang ZigBee-Thermostate
und die haben echt hardcore gesagt,
ich hab jetzt, äh, Fritz deckt die rote Pest aus Berlin.
Hängt bei mir jetzt...
Wobei, die sind gar nicht...
Warum sind die eigentlich nicht rot?
Fritzbox ist auch rot.
Hängt bei mir jetzt am...
an der Heizung.
Und ich muss sagen, die Dinger machen einen deutlich besseren...
Also, die sind auch deutlich...
Die sind auch viel teurer und eigentlich auch viel zu unsinnig teuer, ja.
Aber...
Die machen einen viel besseren Eindruck.
Die sind gut verarbeitet.
Die funktionieren.
Das einzig Dumme an denen ist,
dass die bis zu 15 Minuten brauchen können,
bis die ihre Werte abgerufen haben.
Was jetzt für eine automatische Heizungssteuerung
jetzt nicht so problematisch ist,
weil du steu...
Du regelst ja die Temperatur so über den Tag weg
und ob das jetzt 15 Minuten früher oder später,
das macht's nicht so.
Aber wenn man beispielsweise sagt,
hey, ich will jetzt, äh, keine Ahnung,
wir setzen uns jetzt gleich ins Wohnzimmer,
oder Abendessen oder so,
und ich drück dann eben Home Assistant auf,
äh, jetzt Heizung im Wohnzimmer anmachen,
dann ist es ein bisschen doof,
dass es teilweise bis zu 15 Minuten dauern kann,
bis die wirklich angehen.
Was auch kein wirklich richtig großes Problem ist,
weil du kannst einfach auf den Knopf drücken,
dann holst du dich das sofort.
Hast du Fenstersensoren?
Ja, hab ich.
Hab ich überhaupt bei AliExpress gekauft.
Ich kann euch mal was zeigen,
in der Hoffnung, ich leake nicht wieder was.
Fenstersensors...
Nee, kann ich euch nicht zeigen.
Das ist auf der Startseite.
Da leake ich...
Da leake ich die Haltestelle,
von der ich fahr.
Aber hab ich...
Ich hab mal...
Ich hab mal bei Banggood
für unter 10 Euro das Stück,
ich kauf die...
Ich kauf so Sachen eigentlich immer ganz gerne,
wenn sie unter 10 Dollar das Stück sind,
mal nen Riesenpack gekauft,
weil die...
Das war irgendwie Banggood Jubiläum,
Sale vom Hersteller und sonst wie.
Die kosten normalerweise irgendwie 25 Dollar oder so,
und das war dann unter 10.
Da hab ich gleich nen Riesenpack gekauft.
Ich hab immer noch ne Kiste voll mit 8 Stück oder so.
Kannst du Opera...
Kannst du Opera als Browser empfehlen?
Nein, mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Weiß ich auch zu wenig zu.
Ich weiß nur noch, dass Opera jetzt den Chinesen gehört.
Den China-Chinesen.
So, als erstes haben wir bestellt,
by the way, wo ich grad dabei bin,
wo einer gefragt hat, Thermostate.
Äh, Sando, ich wollte imnächst tatsächlich mal versuchen,
ein Video zu machen, ohne euch zu viel leaken.
Brave Browser hab ich ausprobiert,
hab ich auch keinen Anwendungszweck mehr für.
Wozu?
Einzig Gute ist,
kann der mittlerweile YouTube im Background playen,
auf iOS?
Das, jupp.
Ähm, das macht aber Zigbee und Z-Wave und WLAN
heute auch schon ohne Internet laufen.
Das Problem sind die Hersteller,
die wollen, dass man sich zu irgendeinem Webservice verbindet,
dass man seine Heizung anmachen kann.
Aber die können mich mal am Arsch lecken,
sowas verwende ich nicht.
Ich seh's nicht ein, dass mein Internet funktionieren muss
und der Cloud-Anbieter funktionieren muss,
dass ich meine Heizung anschalten kann.
Ich glaub, es geht los.
Ähm, was ich mir zum Testen kaufen wollte,
ist ein...
Bluetooth...
Ich kann einmal schreiben.
Das Teil.
Just for fun.
Ich wollte mir das Teil kaufen.
Oh, guck mal, wie viel kostet der hier gerade?
Moment, Moment.
Lull.
Just for fun, weil...
Ähm...
Das kann man Custom-Firmware flashen.
Und ihr wisst,
ich steh auf alles, was man Custom-Firmware flashen kann.
Die kann man flashen, ja.
Was machen die eigentlich?
Kann man dort irgendwas einstellen
oder ist das eine reine Anzeige?
Was kann man dann mehr?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Hahaha.
Bitcoins minen kannst du dann da drauf.
Guck mal, hier ist die Custom...
Hier ist die Custom-Firmware.
Für diese Dinger.
Alter, ist das billig bei...
Bei den Chinesen.
Nice.
Leute, ein...
Moment, das ist G-Bait.
Das ist G-Bait.
Das ist wieder so ein AliExpress-G-Bait-Ding.
Die Tasche kostet 1,46.
Das Thermostat kostet 10 Euro.
Hahaha.
G-G-G-G-G-G-G-G-Baited.
Aber richtig G-Baited.
Wobei das drei Stück sind für 10.
Das stimmt.
Das ist trotzdem eine ganze Ecke billiger als bei AliExpress.
Äh.
Schwachsinn.
Es ist bei AliExpress eine ganze Ecke billiger als bei Amazon.
Warte mal.
14 durch 4 kostet das eine 3.
Und das andere ist 10 durch 3.
Na gut, das sind äh...
3, ja.
Also.
Das heißt,
im Endeffekt ist ähm...
Sogar der 3er-Pack billiger ein bisschen.
Bisschen.
Nicht viel, aber.
Erstmal 30 Stück kaufen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Voraussichtlich 5. Mai.
Okay, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel.
35 Euro.
Okay, gibt's die Dinger irgendwo aus dem...
Okay, China.
China.
What?
Okay.
Du findest wieder die Hälfte nicht bei AliExpress.
Alter.
Smart.
Na was muss ich denn suchen, wenn ich den Kram finde?
Oh fuck, fuck.
Verklickt, verklickt, verklickt, verklickt.
Ah, hier unten kommen noch mehr.
Okay.
Neue Version.
2020.
Was ist denn der Unterschied dazwischen?
Das ist doch alles das gleiche, oder?
Oh, guck mal.
Hier kosten 3 Stück nur 9 Euro.
Und hier kostet eins 2 Euro.
Das wird ja immer billiger.
Sparchamp ist da.
Alles klar.
Special Line.
Das sollte man auf jeden Fall machen.
Dann gibt's auch keine Probleme mit dem Zoll.
So, wir gucken mal kurz.
Wir gucken mal kurz bei Banggood.
Ah.
Sekunde.
Moment.
Wo kann ich jetzt zurück?
Thermometer.
So, und jetzt müssen wir auswählen.
Schiff aus Deutschland.
Gibt's nix?
Nein.
Es lohnt sich einfach, bei den Chinesen zu gucken.
3,04 Euro.
Bei Amazon 10 Euro.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Bam.
So.
Moment.
Leute, die haben sich vertan.
Der Kram kommt aus China.
Das ist doch egal.
Aber das wird von hier geliefert.
Die haben sich vertan, Leute.
Guckt mal.
Die haben sich vertan.
China ist das teuerste.
Der Rest ist am billigsten.
Die haben sich vertan.
Die wollten 3 Euro aus China und 6 Euro aus Rest schreiben.
Garantiert.
Wette ich mit euch.
Das heißt, jetzt erstmal easy buy.
Ah, Moment.
Der Versand.
Wait a minute.
Ah.
Aha.
Noch mehr G-Bait.
Wo war kostenlos?
Hier ist kostenloser Versand.
Aus Spanien.
Aus China.
Chips from China.
Chips from Germany.
Lieferung bis 2. Mai.
Hä?
Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Gibt nicht wirklich Sinn.
Äh.
Guckt mal, was das bei Banggood kost.
Dann bestelle ich mal testweise mal eins von...
Die Chinesen haben eine G-Bait-Abteilung.
Ja, sieht echt so aus.
Guckt mal, in dem Fall ist...
Banggood sogar noch ein bisschen billiger.
Nee, kostet das gleiche.
Aber.
Guckt mal, der Versand.
Das ist das bessere Angebot.
Da kriegst du drei Stück.
Aus Tschechien.
Für 88 Cent.
Germany Priority Mail.
Banggood.
Ist der Preis-Champ kaputt?
Oh, ja.
Den muss ich nachher neu starten.
Der hat wieder den Geist aufgegeben.
Null.
Okay, da bezahlen wir 4,60 Euro.
Bei Amazon bezahlen wir für 1,10 Euro.
Bei Amazon bezahlen wir 10,90 Euro für.
Nee, dann bestellen wir nachher Banggood.
Banggood wird bestellt.
Muss man gleich mal rüberkopieren.
Ich hab vergessen, Banggood.
Beste Seitenname überhaupt.
So, das ist doch nice.
Also 4,60.
4,60 für drei Stück.
Wird der Versand teurer?
Guckt mal, der Versand wird noch nicht mal teurer,
wenn ich mehr nehme.
Das sind auch Chinesen, ja.
Moment, jetzt wird's ja noch billiger.
Sekunde.
Moment.
Die kommen wahrscheinlich jetzt nur aus China, ne?
Chips from China.
Gut, da ist es halt noch ein Ticken billiger,
aber mal drauf geschissen.
Banggood Express ist gut, das landet nie mal im Zoll.
Warum soll man eigentlich das da nehmen,
wenn es länger dauert?
Man könnte auch EU Priority Line nehmen.
Das ist sogar noch besser.
Das ist die Geschichte, wo es nie im Zoll landet.
Ja, das lohnt sich da nicht wirklich, ne?
Guck mal, hier gibt's auch wieder welche aus Tschechien.
Moment, das sind die, die wir gerade hatten, ne?
Und die kommen direkt aus China.
Bestell ich mal nachher eine Packung von
1-3 Business Days.
Jetzt bezahlen wir die Hälfte.
Wir bezahlen weniger als die Hälfte bei Amazon.
Also sind nicht 20 Cent, das sind 5 Euro.
Genau, und die kann man flashen, habe ich nämlich gefunden.
Das hier auf GitHub.
Custom Firmware.
Moment, Moment, es gibt zwei verschiedene.
Warum gibt es zwei verschiedene Firmwares schon wieder?
Guck mal, man kann das sogar OTA flashen.
Wow!
Alter, was ist das für eine Seite, ich krieg Augenkrebs.
Brauchst du wirklich drei Stück von?
Sonst zahlst du nämlich mehr, hä, warum?
Du meinst einer, einer, einer...
Hä, nee, wie, wo, wie,
Warum bezahl ich mehr mit, mit...
Da gibt es ja nur drei.
Das ist ein Thermo...
Das ist ein Thermometer für Luftfeuchtigkeit und
Temperatur, was man halt an die Wand hängen kann.
Ey, ehrlich gesagt, ich wollte es einfach mal ausprobieren.
Nee, ich bestell keine einzelnen.
Ich flash das Ding kaputt und dann ist es im Arsch.
Und bezahlst...
Und 15 bezahlt kannst du auch einen für 10 von Amazon.
Nee, das ist ja bescheuert.
Da werden schon nämlich drei für 15.
Funktioniert super.
Warum ist die Webseite also hässlich?
Funktioniert die dann wenigstens?
Sortful Dev, geht die Seite dann wenigstens?
Weil die sieht, das sieht wirklich
äußerst painstampig aus.
Das ist HTML 5.0, äh, 0.5
Was kann das mit Custom Firmware?
Ja, da bin ich mir auch nicht so ganz sicher.
Erstmal, das wichtigste ist,
es kann geflasht werden.
Okay, Custom kann geflasht werden.
Modern Browser, ja, genau.
Falls ihr es nicht wusstet, für diese Seite
braucht man einen modernen Browser.
Supports, okay, Key Features.
Jetzt kommt's, Key Features.
Supports connection using pin code
and encrypted bind key beacon.
Was bedeutet das überhaupt?
Man kann drei
verschiedene LCD-Screens anzeigen,
die sich abwechseln.
Das ist ein cooles Feature.
Reading measurements from flash.
Boah!
Man kann,
man kann eine History auslesen.
Improve battery life.
Ja, Bestellung ist raus.
Würde ich sagen.
So, und was schreibt der andere zu seiner Homepage?
Okay, der schreibt nichts zu Key Features.
Mich würde ja mal interessieren,
das ist ein ESP32
oder was da drinnen?
Das heißt, der Kram kann auch WLAN?
Oder doch nicht?
Ne, das ist zum Abfragen.
Das ist zum Abfragen.
Das ist zum Abfragen
für den ESP32.
Nicht zum...
Ach, hier ist die Custom Firmware.
Ja, wo ist der Source von der Custom Firmware?
Ja, Moment, warte mal.
Ich muss mal kurz ab...
Alter!
Ja, ich bin wieder Reifen wechseln gewesen.
Ne.
Ich habe gerade festgestellt,
dass...
Moment, ich zeige es euch.
Ich habe ja letztens erst ein Video gemacht.
Ich habe festgestellt,
gerade,
dass das Teil hier
anscheinend Wackelkontakt hat.
Ja, guckt mal.
Max, scroll mal runter.
Scroll mal runter.
Die hatten das Ding an Wackelkontakt.
Einmal...
Einmal falsch dran gewackelt,
ist das Kabel raus.
Ist kein Kabelkontakt mehr.
Das sackt.
Das ist ziemlich mies.
Ja gut, dann...
Dann können wir jetzt ja weitermachen.
Genau, ich habe wieder Reifen drauf gemacht.
Chat weiß Bescheid.
Wie lange war ich denn weg?
Fünf Minuten oder so?
Viel länger kann das doch nicht gewesen sein, oder?
Ich habe einfach mal alle Kabel gewackelt
und das Ding überrascht.
Kommt jetzt.
Ne, ne, ne, die Kabel sind in Ordnung.
Die haben auch so ein Clips.
Ich vermute, dass wirklich
die Steckdose
ein Problem hat, nicht das Kabel.
Ja, kein
Darkmode Paints Champ.
So, okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Also den Kram wollte ich jetzt einkaufen,
haben wir ja gemacht. Custom Firmware.
Genau, also ich bin begeistert, dass das Ding eine Custom Firmware hat.
Und das werden wir mal im Stream ausprobieren.
Finde ich äußerst
nice.
So.
Excellent.
Hätten wir das? Hätten wir das? Können wir den Kram wieder zumachen?
Link habe ich mir kopiert
von Banggood.
Da kaufen wir es, in Tschechien.
Kriege ich
da noch Geld wieder?
Leute, wenn ich als
New User einen Coupon kriege
von 17 Euro, kriege ich dann Geld wieder,
wenn ich das kaufe?
Das wäre doch mal hyper.
Nice.
Da mache ich mir einfach jeden Tag
neue Accounts und bestelle das und da habe ich
Infinite Money Loop.
Ne, ich bezweifle es auch, dass das geht, aber es wäre schon
nice. Die sind ja nicht dumm.
Nicht so wie manche Pizzashops
oder solche Sachen, die sowas
zumindest über die Webseite zulassen.
Ja, Custom Firmware.
Ich gehe mal kurz rein,
wie das flasht.
Ich will einfach nur sehen, wie das flasht.
Okay, die Dinger
sind ganz schön klein, oder?
Oh, da hat er irgendwie...
Da muss man Kabel aufmachen,
das wollen wir ja nicht.
Excellent Flashing.
Okay, es ist anscheinend wirklich
nur eine reine Anzeige.
Aber das ist nicht verkehrt, da sieht man
wie warm es ist.
Ist eine coole Geschichte.
So, wird auch bestellt und geflasht.
Haben wir schon mal?
Haben wir schon mal wieder
Streamprogramm
für die nächsten Streams?
Wir flashen...
Das ist Premiere.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich über Bluetooth
was flashe. Ich habe noch nie über Bluetooth
was geflasht.
Massive IQ.
Bekannte bauen gerade um.
Denen wirst du eine OneWire...
Was für ein Ding?
Eine OneWire Busch Jäger Temperatursensor
in den Raum andrehen.
Ja, gibt Money.
Ja. Aha.
Ja, kann man ja machen.
Wenn man neu baut, ist es eh besser.
Also, wenn ich
heute noch mal bauen würde,
ich hab damals, leider war ich zu low brain,
mir da Gedanken drüber zu machen,
2013, würde ich viel mehr
Leerrohre machen.
Hä? Nee, kann ich auch so.
Bei Bluetooth, also es gibt
auch Sachen, die kannst du bei Bluetooth in Home Assistant
einbinden und die einfachste
Variante ist, ich nehme einfach einen
ESP32 mit Bluetooth und frag den Kram ab
und schick's an Home Assistant.
Haben wir ja gestern, die letzten zwei Tage,
sowas programmiert. Bloß, dass ich für
ähm, für
Mi Flora Sensors programmiert
hab. Die letzten
Tage. Was ist denn das für
eine, für eine Ausgeburt
der Hölle?
What the fuck?
Hat da der Praktikant
gelötet oder was?
Was ist das?
Was?
What the fuck, Alter?
Die Chinesen schlagen
wieder zu. Ach, das ist
ein ESP32
mit DHTL vom Boden.
Okay, das ist eine komische Konstruktion.
Das ist eine ganz, ganz
merkwürdige Konstruktion.
Nee. Nee.
Wirklich nicht.
Guck mal, du kriegst sogar,
du kriegst sogar ein 3D gedrucktes
Gehäuse dabei.
Ha! Eine 200,
eine 200mAh Batterie.
Das Ding
ist nach zwei Tagen leer.
Ich muss jetzt einfach mal kurz gucken, wie viel
Power, oder
guck mal mal.
Doch, Power.
Power consumption. Das Ding
ist, das 200mAh
Akku, das hält zwei Tage.
Ja.
60 micro Ampere.
Das ist, das ist leer
nach einer Woche.
Trotzdem größerer Akku als in einem iPhone.
Quatsch.
iPhone hat einen deutlich größeren Akku.
Oder war das ein Joke, den ich nicht
kapiert hab?
iPhone hat einen iPhone,
6000mAh Akku.
Nee, das ist iPad wahrscheinlich eher.
2500.
Ja.
4000.
Warum ist das iPhone lost?
Hält das so viel kürzer als andere
vergleichbare?
Ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen,
dass sagen wir mal ein aktuelles
Samsung Android jetzt wirklich nennenswert
länger hält als ein iPhone.
Würdest du ein Löt-Kit
bei den Chinesen bestellen?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Geht doch eigentlich.
Ja, der TS100, das ist ja tatsächlich cool.
Aber ich schwöre auf meine
Ersa-Lötstation.
Nano.
Beste.
Okay, vielleicht ein bisschen teurer, aber
beste Investition
für Löt-Stells gewesen, das Teil.
Ja, so ein TS100 kannst du ja kaufen.
Die sind, die sind okay.
Smart-Blume.
Viel zu teuer.
Aber das Ding sieht wirklich echt
wie die Ausgeburt des Bösen aus,
hier.
Da noch mit diesem scheppen USB-Anschluss
oder scheppen, ich glaub das ist gar kein USB,
mit dem scheppen Batterie-Anschluss, ey.
Heck, wait.
Alter, die Dinger sind ja mega
hässlich, was du dir bei denen kaufen kannst.
Das sieht schon
gar schon ein bisschen anstößig aus,
ehrlich gesagt, das Ding.
Okay, also, sehr gut.
Also haben wir schon zwei Sachen am Start.
Nämlich die Steckdosen
und der,
das Thermometer.
Leute, meine Katze
frisst die letzten zwei Tage wie verrückt, ne.
Ich muss Katzenfutter bestellen, fällt mir grad auf.
Und meine Katze steht extrem
auf das hier.
Huhn und Lachs.
Huhn, Chicken und Lachs. Beste.
Da steht die
unglaublich drauf.
Das find die nice.
Die frisst seit zwei Tagen, ey.
Die hört gar nicht mal auf
zu fressen. Ja.
Meine passt da nicht mehr drauf.
Doch, ne.
Meine ist ja klein.
Ist hier so
in der Mitte irgendwo.
Ja, da muss ich auf jeden Fall wieder
ne Packung bestellen, am besten gleich die große.
One time purchase.
Katzenfutter, beste.
Normalerweise kann man 400 Gramm oder 2 Kilo
auswählen. Wo ist das hier?
2 Gramm sind das.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Wo kann ich denn das aus?
Ach, 2 Kilo sind das hier.
Ja, 2 Kilo ist gut, bam.
Pepo-Fett für die Katz.
Mjam-Mjam, Catfood.
Mjam-Mjam.
Mjam-Mjam klingt wie so ein Instant-Rahmen.
Wie so Instant-Rahmen, japanische Instant-Rahmen.
Mjam-Mjam.
Subscription für Katzenfutter.
Ja, das ist Amazon, die versuchen das immer anzudrehen.
Okay, gut.
Haben wir das Wichtigste schon mal geklärt.
So, jetzt können wir nochmal zu ein paar anderen Sachen kommen.
Ich brauche noch
einen USB-Hub.
Allerdings, ich weiß nicht,
ob es sowas gibt, einen USB-Hub
mit möglichst langem Kabel.
Also,
ich würde gerne hier bei mir an die Tür,
bei mir an der Tür hängt eine Steckdose
mit, also eine schaltbare
Steckdose mit zwei USB-Steckern dran.
Aber, ich würde gerne USB-Geräte
ein paar auf den Schrank legen.
Und da bräuchte ich so
würde man sagen,
zwei bis drei Meter USB-Kabel am USB-Hub.
Ob es sowas
gibt?
Ein USB-Hub mit drei Meter USB-Kabel?
Ich meine, man könnte eine Verlängerung nehmen, ja?
Einfach
wiren das USB. Ah, yes.
Der Keksin.
Schau mal, der Keksin.
Warum ist das so teuer?
Warum kostet das, fuck,
65 Euro für ein USB-Hub?
Ist das vergoldet
innen drin von Amazon oder was?
Oder ist das auch noch so ein komischer Kokona-Stecker?
Nee, keine Festplatten
auf dem Schrank.
Warum ist der so teuer?
Aber das ist
ein langes Kabel.
Weil man ein x-beliebiges Kabel nehmen kann.
Ah, man kann das...
Moment.
Ich brauche ja den USB.
Ich brauche ja das Ding nur...
Moment, ich bin ja eigentlich doof.
Ich brauche keinen USB-Hub.
Ich brauche ja eigentlich nur den Strom
vom USB.
Ich brauche ja, ich brauche nur den Strom vom USB.
Ich brauche gar keinen.
Weil die Geräte selbst sind wireless.
Ich brauche ja gar keine Daten oder sonst wie.
Also im Prinzip
einfach
nur, ich bräuchte einfach nur
einen...
Ach nee, Schwachsinn.
Schwachsinn.
Ich brauche schon ein USB-Kabel.
Weil ich habe ja da keinen Stecker.
Das ist ja der Sinn dahinter gewesen.
Ich habe ja gar keinen
Anschluss für
das Netzteil da.
Ich will ja eigentlich einen USB-Port,
der nur über USB geht.
Aber das geht wahrscheinlich gar nicht, ne?
Wenn ich einen USB...
Das ist ja eigentlich...
Wenn ich den USB-Hub anschließe
an einen USB-Port zum Stromversorgen,
dann ist das ja limitiert auf das,
was so ein Einzelner kann, ne?
Also sprich,
hier steht was drauf von
5 Volt, 2 Ampere.
Das heißt,
damit werde ich wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr als
sagen wir mal
3 Geräte
irgendwie sinnig betreiben können.
Anker Power Speed.
Was für ein Ding?
Aha.
Ach, nimmt der 2 USB-Ports
oder was?
Anker Power Port Speed 5.
Wie schließt man das an?
Nee, nee, nee.
Das kommt nicht
in USB, ne?
Das kommt an die Steckdose.
Ah, nee, dann...
Ja, dann muss ich mir
das weiter Gedanken machen.
Wisst ihr, was ich bräuchte?
Ich bräuchte einen USB-Port,
einen USB-Hub, der nur mit
USB-Stecker geht und dafür mit 2.
Ich will einen, der nur
vom USB-Port geht, weil ich habe ja keinen Stecker.
Ich meine, ich habe einen Stecker,
aber den brauche ich für was anderes.
Ah, das glaube ich.
Ist keine so gute Idee.
Was ist das?
Monka.
Ah, oben sind Daten und unten ist nur Charge.
Aber meine Steckdose hat keinen USB-C.
Nee.
Ohne Sprite ist doch was ganz anderes.
Aber die übertreiben es hier ganz schön
mit Stecker, oder?
Flup, Flup, Flup, Flup, Flup.
12 Volt, 3 Ampere.
Ja, klar.
Ich war es nicht genau.
Ich habe einen USB-C-Port am PC,
ja, aber das bringt mir ja nichts.
Ich will es ja an die Steckdose an der Tür machen.
Die hat nur diese normalen.
Das sieht aus wie so ein Billig-Ding von AliExpress.
Ist es wahrscheinlich auch.
Ah, Müll brauchen wir nicht.
Da muss ich mir nochmal Gedanken drüber machen.
Ich glaube,
ich glaube, das ist nicht so der Weisheitsletzterschluss.
Was ist das?
Nee, das muss ich mir nochmal überlegen.
Okay, also.
Gucken wir nochmal.
Gucken wir mal was anderes.
Also USB, das schiebe ich erstmal auf.
Genau, dann wollte ich mir noch das, was wir letztens,
wo wir letztens programmiert haben,
da wollte ich mir noch einen weiteren 3er-Pack kaufen.
Weil man macht ja schnell mal einen kaputt.
Und ich fand das Ding wirklich äußerst angenehm,
damit was zu basteln.
Was bezahlt man da gerade bei Banggood
für Banggood?
Was ist das denn?
Ja, das sind aber nicht die
ESP32-Version.
Die ESP32-Version haben die hier irgendwie gar nicht, ne?
Sauerei.
Anzeige ist raus, Banggood.
Hier, das ist eine ESP32.
Okay, der kostet natürlich schon deutlich weniger
als bei Amazon, ne?
Bei Amazon bezahlst du 6,66 das Stück
und bei AliExpress
bezahlst du 3,66.
Halt wie immer die Hälfte, aber die Delivery-Time
ist halt wieder jenseits
von allem.
Und Banggood hat irgendwie keine.
Warum hat Banggood keine?
B-B-Banggood.
Easy DHL
erstmal 60 Euro, ja.
Ne, haben die nicht.
Hast du
smarte E26
GU10-Lampen?
Was sind denn GU10-Lampen?
E27
ist die ganz normale Fassung, oder ist das die kleine?
Ich kann das immer nicht auseinander...
Wie soll das sein?
Brauchen wir nicht.
GU10?
What?
Habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Ich habe zum größten
zwar nicht alles, aber ich habe zum
größten Teil
so welche von denen
hier.
Allerdings
nicht mit den offiziellen
Preisen von der Homepage, weil
die haben sie nicht mehr alle.
Was das hier kostet, da müsst ihr rumgucken.
Das kriegt ihr für die Hälfte.
Das ist der Witz.
64 Euro, das kriegst du für fast die Hälfte,
wenn du mal ein bisschen rumguckst.
Und man muss dazu sagen,
eigentlich ist es auch total
übertrieben, denn
also ich glaube zumindest, die meisten Leute
übertreiben es total.
Man braucht in der Regel gar kein RGB.
Wie viele bekommt man für 65 Euro?
Natürlich eine, was sonst?
Wie gesagt, du kriegst sie für die Hälfte
ungefähr, wenn du mal ein bisschen rumguckst.
Aber die würde ich auch nie kaufen
für alles,
weil die meisten Leute
brauchen gar kein RGB.
Die meisten Leute wollen eigentlich nur
eine dimmbare Lampe haben
und dimmbare Lampen kosten halt
nochmal deutlich weniger.
Und da kannst du die auch holen.
RGB ist eine coole Sache,
aber braucht man bei den meisten Sachen gar nicht.
So, und wenn jetzt eine dimmbare
Lampe nicht reicht, das nächste
ist, was die Leute haben wollen, vielleicht eine,
wo du die Farbtemperatur einstellen kannst.
Aber so richtiges RGB
braucht man eigentlich ganz selten,
weil du mal ernsthaft, wo brauchst du richtiges RGB?
Wo willst du
deine Deckenlampe
auf grün schalten?
Das kommt nicht oft vor.
Das willst du vielleicht im Wohnzimmer, wenn du irgendwie
so Ambilight Extension oder sowas machst,
aber ansonsten
ist das doch
jetzt nicht so ein breites
Anwendungsgebiet.
Im Streamingzimmer, was im Streamingzimmer?
Digga!
Lost, Alter, richtig lost hier
die Leute. Kann man machen, aber
ich behaupte mal, dass von
sagen wir mal, von
so Smart
Wifi Lampen, die sich jemand kauft,
braucht er vielleicht
und das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen zu hoch
5 mit richtig RGB.
Der Rest reicht dimmbar
und eventuell dimmbar mit Farbtemperatur.
Weil mit Farbtemperaturanpassung
kannst du ja immer noch zwischen
ein bisschen
weiß-bläulich und rötlich
umschalten. Das reicht ja in
99% der Fälle aus.
RGB ist, wenn du dein Zimmer
lila machen willst oder so.
Was hältst du von Philips Hue?
Kann ich nichts zu sagen, hatte ich nie im Einsatz.
So, ich brauche
aber noch was. Ich brauche einen Aufsatz
für mein
ich habe so eine Heizluft
so ein Teil hier.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz
sicher, welchen ich davon habe. Wahrscheinlich
den hier. Ich brauche einen
Aufsatz, der das Ganze kleiner macht.
Das ist so groß vorne
und auch zu viel
Luft. Ja, sowas hier, genau.
Sowas in der Richtung brauche
ich. Genau, genau.
Excellent. Im Prinzip ist das
einfach nur Metalltrichter, oder?
9 Millimeter, ja.
Nozzle.
Rapid Reduction Nozzle.
Oh, was ist denn das?
Oh, jetzt wird es
aber echt
Jetzt wird es aber echt Massive Advanced.
Was gibt es denn hier alles?
Wofür genau brauche
ich so...
Hä? Was brauche ich das denn alles
für meine Heizluft?
Was ist das überhaupt?
Hat irgendjemand eine...
Was ist das Ding hier?
Ist das so, wo man so
wo man so aufs Knie
Reflexe klopfen kann, oder wie?
Was ist das?
Ach, ich kann es dafür...
Ah, das ist, wenn es einen juckt und man hat die Hand voll.
Crapmaker.
Ich erkenne es auch nicht.
Die Dinger verstehe ich ja.
Das hier weiß ich sogar.
Also was das für ein Teil ist, keine Ahnung.
Aber wofür die Dinger gut sind,
kenne ich sogar.
Hier kannst du was zum Löten drüberlegen.
Und dann pustest du und dann lötest du es zusammen,
weil sich hier die heiße Luft staut.
Moin Max, hast du noch Kontakt zu
Isle of Cookies? Warum fragst du das?
Hast du dich gestern schon mal gefragt?
Wie kommst du denn da jetzt drauf?
Hast du das schon beantwortet?
Schaber-Ersatz.
Was ist das alles?
So ein China... Boah!
Alter!
Willst du deine Wohnung abfackeln,
oder was?
Die China-Chinesen sind am Start.
Das kommt mir nicht ins Haus.
Äh...
Da fackelst du die Hütte ab.
Ist das ein April-Scherz?
Ist das ein Witz?
Das heißt nicht, es stinkt.
Okay, das ist ein April-Scherz.
Das ist ein April-Scherz.
Damit lötest du doch nichts.
Das ist ein Witz, das Ding, oder?
Du schweißt damit doch nicht.
Okay, anscheinend...
Anscheinend meinen die das wirklich ernst.
Moment...
Das heißt wirklich, es stinkt?
Oder was?
Das ist jetzt für mich kein guter Name
für so ein Ding.
Wenn es stinkt, ist in der Regel was kaputt.
Der Stream laggt?
Oh ne, laggt der Stream, Leute?
Nope, der Stream laggt nix.
Null Drop Frames,
das liegt bei dir, das Problem.
Gut, was auch immer.
Also...
Ich hab keine Ahnung,
was der Kram
alles ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Moment, hier.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das alles ist, aber...
Wow! Moment, es hat eben noch 12 Euro gekostet.
Warum kostet das auf einmal 49?
49 Euro für so ein paar Aufsätze?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, Leute.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Da nehm ich hier den kleinen Aufsatz
Ich mein, 5,30 für so ein Popel-Aufsatz
ist mir schon eigentlich zu teuer.
Das reicht.
Bam. Fertig.
Zack.
Das stand...
Ohne Mist.
Das stand doch eben noch bei 12 Euro.
Hier.
Ah, ich hab mich verguckt.
12,50
49. Lull.
Lull Triple U.
Ja.
Ich hab nichts gesagt.
Wegen deinem USB. Guck dir mal USB-Steckerleisten an.
Nee, das kann ich ja nicht verwenden.
Ich brauch ja was,
was ich über den USB-Anschluss betreibe
und nicht in die Steckdose stecke.
Okay, den Kram haben wir jetzt.
Excellent. Next.
Brauch ich denn als nächstes?
Ist nix mehr großartig, oder?
Ach, doch!
Wo ich mir noch einen zweiten Satz von kaufen will,
aber da hab ich jetzt vergessen, wie das heißt.
Die Dinger sind richtig Big Brain.
Ähm...
Schlauch,
der auch löten kann.
Moment, wie hieß...
Wie heißen die Dinger denn?
Schlauch.
Ich hab vergessen, wie die Dinger heißen, aber die sind ultra praktisch.
Da will ich mir noch ein Set von kaufen.
Sowas hier, genau.
Lötverbinder.
Genau, da will ich mir...
Die Dinger sind richtig nice.
Hab ich jetzt schon ein paar mal verwendet und sind richtig...
POC.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade beim Thema POC sind.
Ähm...
Wenn ich das selbst machen würde, ne?
Dann würde ich POCers nennen.
Dann würde ich sagen, hey POCers!
Und dann würde er dann sagen...
Was weiß ich...
Die aktuelle Uhrzeit ist 21.19 Uhr.
Dann würde mir POCers antworten.
Und...
Ich finde, das ist ein ausgefallener Name.
Da versteht...
Der Mist versteht dann auch nicht irgendein Wort
für POCers
und fühlt sich angesprochen.
Also wenn ich mal irgendwie so ein custom
Assistant mir aus Github-Projekten zusammen baue,
dann wird der POCers heißen.
Genau.
Was kann so ein Lötverbinder?
Mein Gott, du brauchst ja einen Popfilter.
Ich brauch keinen Popfilter, ich brauch nur einen Popfilter, wenn ich sag...
Wenn ich hier explizit
reinpoppe in das Mikrofon.
Das hat einen Popfilter drauf, aber gegen mein
Ultra in das Mikrofon
reingespreche kann er nichts machen.
Da ist ein Popfilter drauf.
So, ich kann ja mal zeigen, was so ein Lötverbinder macht.
Äh...
Die Dinger sind richtig nice.
Der Bastelbruder.
Ich hab doch letztens ein Video gesehen
von...
Wie heißen die Dinger denn auf Englisch?
Wie heißen die Dinger denn auf...
Solder...
Joints...
Genau, und da hab ich letztens erst
ein Video zu gesehen
und das war eigentlich ganz gut,
weil der hat das auch durchgestricken.
Moment, wie heißt dieser Typ?
Cleave...
Irgendwas...
Genau, Solder...
Da hab ich letztens...
Hier, genau.
Der zeigt das eigentlich ganz gut,
was das macht.
Ich scroll jetzt mal ein bisschen vor.
Also sprich...
Also, bei diesen Dingern funktioniert
folgendermaßen, in der Mitte ist Lötzinn,
hier außen
ist ein Schrumpfschlauch
und das da,
diese Farben,
das ist Heißkleber.
Also sprich, was passiert ist,
ich zeig's euch einfach mal.
Ups.
Verklickt, 0 W.
Genau, so.
Übrigens, der, guck,
der hat auch so einen Aufsatz auf seinem Heißluftteil,
dass es nur noch kleiner
Gebläse bläst.
Ja, das muss man nicht wirklich machen.
Ich mach das immer so,
dass ich beides links und rechts reinstecke,
sodass es hier übereinander geht,
aber Geschmackssache.
Also, du machst das da drüber,
schiebst es da rein,
so, und das hier ist Heißkleber,
das blaue ist Heißkleber,
hier ist auch Heißkleber und hier ist Lötzinn.
Alter, was macht der denn da?
Aufschieben, nein, das Ding.
So, und jetzt
hast du die Möglichkeit,
entweder nimmst du ein Feuerzeug
und hältst das dran,
die letzten Schläuche hab ich alle mit dem Feuerzeug gemacht,
weil ich eben keinen Aufsatz
für mein Heißluftgebläse hatte
und es sonst viel zu, viel zu groß war,
einfach ein Feuerzeug
dranhalten, bisschen hin und her
wackeln und gut ist
und ein bisschen länger in die Mitte,
dass es schmilzt.
So, aber wenn er das jetzt zeigt, dann sieht man,
dass das echt eine gute Idee ist.
Aufmach an
und jetzt Puststelz machen,
damit das
Cut 6 verlängern.
Das könntest du machen, aber für so ganz kleine
Drähtchen wie bei Netzwerk ist es,
brauchst du eine kleine Sache auch,
ja, und die mögen das ja auch
nicht unbedingt, wenn man die Isolierung aufmacht,
aber ja, würdest du wahrscheinlich hinbekommen.
Aber um Cut 6 zu verlängern, würde ich wahrscheinlich
irgendwie einen Stecker nehmen, wo man das
auf der einen Seite reinstecken, auf der anderen Seite reinstecken,
gut ist. So, guck,
es gibt Schrumpf, Schrumpfstelz,
Schrumpfschlauchstelz
und das ist Heißkleber, der schmilzt
jetzt und klebt das Wasser dicht ab, also das ist
eigentlich ne richtig geile Idee.
Ich kauf mir kein, ähm,
Mikrofon, was
auf dem Tisch, ich hab nen Mikro, ich hab nen,
die Videos auf, hört ihr nicht den Unterschied?
Die Videos, die ich auf YouTube aufnehme, nehm ich
doch mit nem komplett anderen Mikrofon auf, als
jetzt hier streamen soll. Im Stream
hab ich mein MMX 300 auf, einfach weil's
angenehm ist, hier 3 Stunden zu hocken
mit nem Headset auf. Wenn ich Videos für YouTube aufnehme,
dann mach ich das mit, äh, meinem
ollen Pluietti mit nem richtig
schönen, dicken, fetten Popschutz oben drauf.
So, so ein Puschel ist da oben drauf.
Und der hier, das MMX 300 hat halt so
so, hat ja auch nen Popschluss,
Popschutz. So,
also wird geblasen.
Der Heißkleber klebt's wasserdicht ab.
Und jetzt, in der Mitte, volle
Pulle. Oh, das Mikrofon
hört sich anders an.
So.
Okay, das ist ne andere Sorte als die, die
ich hab.
Weil, bei meinen, wenn ich hier das
Feuerzeug, vielleicht macht das auch nicht heiß genug, keine Ahnung,
ähm, als ich das Feuerzeug
drangehalten hab, hab ich richtig gesehen,
wie das Lötzinn hier die Kabel langgelaufen
ist. Aber es ist ne coole
Technik, das ist ne coole Idee. 20 Monate
Kyokun, massive Subscription hier.
Dankeschön, 20 Monate,
das ist ja, so viel Hyper-Subscriber
kann ich ja gar nicht drücken, ähm,
richtig Poggers.
Ja, das kommt mir auch vor, als heizt der
mit 50 Grad oder so, da geht ja überhaupt nichts
vorwärts.
Ja, doch, doch, es schmilzt, es schmilzt.
Das wird wahrscheinlich schon so seine 300 Grad sein.
So, 250, 300 Grad.
Zumindest
kann, dass der da drangreifen kann, normalerweise
wird das Kabel ganz schön warm.
Der so, so richtig, so 100
prozentig gut schmelzen tut's nicht,
ne? Also, wie gesagt,
ich hab das,
wir brauchen Omega Sub,
ja, ja, ja, also, also quasi
die Kombination aus
Ja,
genau sowas.
Ja, aber da, dafür
sind die Dinger da und das ist ne echt coole Geschichte.
So, jetzt schneidet er's
doch irgendwann durch und man sieht,
dass es bei ihm überhaupt nicht richtig
zusammengegangen ist.
Aber das ist auch ein relativ dickes Kabel,
muss man sagen, was er da hat.
Naja, also das ist, das ist
ziemlich Painschampig.
Wenn du, wenn du das, wenn du das von Hand löten,
löten würdest, wäre das schon
ne ganze Ecke ordentlicher.
Guckt, also das ist, das hat Kontakt,
das ist zusammen, aber
so schön ist es
net. Also das ist von Hand gelötet
definitiv besser, aber das Problem
hatte ich da auch nicht, ich hab das nur mit dünneren
Kabel gemacht und da hab ich richtig gesehen,
wie das Lötzint komplett durch
Kabel geflossen ist.
Das ist ganz schön dickes Kabel, was er da hat.
Thick Cable.
So'n Ding,
so'n Ding bräuchte ich mal, da suchen wir
jetzt mal nach Amazon dazu.
Ich hab zwar schon eine,
aber die verwende ich nie, ich bräuchte sowas
kleines. Dritte
Hand löten. Und wir reden
nicht hier, Chat.
Nicht wieder hier gleich
unanständige Dinger posten im Chat.
So.
Was gibt's denn hier alles? Mit Lupe
Lötrauch
Absaugung.
Okay, das ist cool, die Sache ist
bloß die, wohin saugten das ab?
Oh
Fuck, Alter.
Was sind, was
sind, sieben, Moment.
700 Schweizer Franken zu Euro.
631,
okay.
Wohin saugten das ab?
Ist da ein Filter drin, oder wie
ist das? Ah, okay.
Boah,
das ist mir zu teuer.
Das ist mir zu teuer.
Wer atmet nicht gerne Lötdämpfer
ein? Ich hab,
wisst ihr, was ich aktuell benutze?
Wisst ihr, was ich aktuell benutze,
um, äh, Löt,
äh, ja,
Wolken abzusaugen?
Den USB-Ventilator-Champ, sowas
da.
Das zieh, das pustet's dann einfach im Raum
rum. Und danach, wenn ich fertig
bin, mach ich Fenster auf.
Einfach einen USB-Ventilator daneben gestellt.
Ich will keinen Schlauch aus dem Fenster
legen. Aber sowas
hier bräuchte ich ernsthaft mal.
Ich hab welche, also
ich hab sowas, allerdings nur sowas,
das hat auch, also das, was ich hab, hat auch
solche, solche Ärmel.
Das Dumme ist nur,
dass man die quasi entweder
am Tisch,
also du musst quasi am Tisch was festschrauben,
um das dann zu machen. Das ist total
unbequem.
Das verwende ich nicht.
Ich, ich würd
eher sagen, also ich, ich, ich
hätte lieber sowas, was ich auf den Tisch
stellen kann. Einfach zwei Kabel zusammen.
Es wird ja immer abgedrehter.
Sowas hier,
sowas hier bräuchte ich mal, ne?
Die Lupe und das Gedöns brauch ich
net. Ich bräuchte einfach sowas
zum Festhalten. Und gut, aber nicht mit so viel
Weckschnack dabei. Einfach ein paar, einfach
ein paar Zangen. Also das sieht, das
sieht ja aus wie aus irgendeinem Hentai oder so
der Kram.
Wo ist, wo ist eigentlich der Sibaro, wenn man
da von solchen Sachen spricht?
Gib ein
Löthilfe.
Ja, komm, der gleiche Crap.
Oh, das ist bestimmt qualitativ sehr hochwertig
für 3,70.
Gibt's das auch mit RGB?
Wir wissen ja, dass mit RGB
prinzipiell alles besser wird.
Lötkolben-Set für
1899, ja.
Da ist auch Monkas
Ist da noch ein Multimeter
dabei oder was?
Ne.
Die Chinesen wieder, eh.
Bestimmt auch ultra hochwertiges Zeug.
Sieht aus wie ein Gerät
beim Zahnarzt.
LED brauch ich nicht, das steht
bei mir alles unter dem Elgato Ring Light.
Gibt's nicht einfach
was total simples?
Sowas hier vielleicht.
Einfach was total simples.
So ein bisschen Gewicht und einfach
zwei Dinger zum Klipsen und gut ist.
Ne Lupe brauch ich eh net.
Hauptsache billig.
Okay.
Alter, das sieht ja echt pervers aus
das Zeug.
Wisst ihr, was ich machen sollte?
Ich hab ja sowas hier in der Richtung schon.
Sowas ähnliches.
Sowas ähnliches wie das
hier hab ich ja schon.
Ich könnte einfach dauerhaftes an meinen
Tisch dran machen.
Und halt permanent dran lassen.
Hol dir lieber sowas, was aussieht
wie ne GoPro. Sowas da.
Was hat
der da oben?
Moment, ist das ein PC-Lüfter?
Moment.
Ist das die Massive Brain
Absaugung oder wie?
Wenn es schon nicht mehr reicht, dass man das
einatmet, wenn man das explizit ins
Gesicht geblasen
bekommen will oder wie?
By the way, der Lüfter hat gar keinen
angeschlossen.
Tentakel-Shit. Und nur mal, dass ich das richtig
verstehe, dass da unten ist ein Gewicht
oder wie? Wie kriege ich das an den Tisch dran?
Smoke-Fan
Suck Smoke.
Ja, der suckt den Smoke.
Wohin? In dein Gesicht?
In your face
suckt der.
Das ist ja ne billig
Konstruktion, Alter.
Das sieht aus wie ein Meme-Bild. Ja, ist es anscheinend.
Aber nicht. Die meinen das ernst.
Guck mal, das bläst dir voll ins Gesicht.
Wenn du da dahinten... Okay, du kannst natürlich
in die andere Richtung machen.
Aber das ist mal ne... What the fuck?
Viermal Absaugung... Ach nee, das ist ne Drohne.
Ich dachte, das sind viermal
Absaugungsdinger. Ich hoffe,
dass es relativ schwer unten, dass es auch
ordentlich steht.
Wie schwer... Wie viel wiegt denn das?
Ich weiß nicht.
Hier. Ein halbes Kilo.
Ist die Base
magnetisch? Vielleicht
ist es gar nicht so schlecht.
Vielleicht ist es wirklich gar nicht so übel.
Die finden es alle
voll geil.
Also, habe ich es richtig verstanden?
Irgendjemand aus dem Chat hat das, so ein Teil, oder?
Tentakel-Champ. Ja,
Hentai-Champ.
Gefällt dies.
Du hast das auch? Okay.
Das ist das USB-Kabel für diesen
billigen... für diesen komischen
Mainboard-Lüfter.
Das sieht
echt fail aus mit diesem Mainboard.
Oder mit diesem komischen
mini, mini
Router-Switch-Lüfter und
komische Konstruktion
auf jeden Fall.
Vor allem, wie er sich erstmal das Kabel
ablötet hier, ne?
Erstmal schönes Kabel über
Nötkolben hängen.
Was ist die beste Steckdose zum Stromverbrauch
auszulesen?
Ja, eine, die du
flashen kannst.
Aber da ist immer schwierig was zu finden.
Es sei denn, du willst Z-Wave
verwenden. Für Z-Wave habe ich eine super
Steckdose. Davon habe ich auch
fünf, glaub ich sogar mehr als fünf, mindestens
fünf Stück im Haus.
Da habe ich die
hier. Weil bei Z-Wave
ist es ja nämlich so,
bei Notebooks billiger gab es die,
ähm,
weil bei Z-Wave ist es ja so,
dass jedes Gerät, was an der Steckdose
steckt, das Netzwerk
erweitert.
Ein,
kannst du ein Emoji-Font für
Manjaro, wo man weit wie es geht
alle Emojis abdecken kann? Also ich habe,
habe ich hier ein Emoji-Font installiert?
Ah, ne,
das ist Firefox. Firefox hat ein Emoji-Font
mit dabei. Moment, habe ich ein Emoji-Font
hier installiert? Müssen wir mal im Terminal
probieren? Nein,
habe ich nicht, Leute.
Ich habe kein Emoji-Font installiert.
Doch, habe ich. Habe ich.
Okay, probieren wir mal aus.
Gibt es ein Emoji-Test
Skript? Gibt es
Shithub Bash, oder
Shithub Bash Emoji-Test?
Gibt es doch bestimmt irgend so eine Schleife.
Emoji-Test,
jawoll, zeig her.
Was macht der da?
Ich will einfach,
ich will einfach
ein Programm, was einfach alle Emojis ausgibt,
die es gibt und dann gucken, was auf der Shell funktioniert
und was nicht. Was ist das?
Ah, crap.
Okay, wir können
was anderes machen. Ich habe die Idee,
was wir machen, Leute. Wir machen Wim
auf. Ja, blub.
Emoji.txt
So, und wir kopieren jetzt einfach
die komplette Seite da rein. Easy.
So, und jetzt gucken wir, was geht.
Oh, ich glaube, das hat,
das ist kaputt gegangen beim Kopieren.
Moment, Moment, Leute.
Set, Paste.
Ah, yes.
Ein paar Sachen sind immer noch
kaputt.
Na, hoffen wir mal, dass das jetzt funktioniert. Okay.
Also.
Okay, ich würde sagen,
der Emoji-Font ist relativ komplett.
Richtig pfeifert, ne?
Ich würde sagen, der Emoji-Font ist tatsächlich
ziemlich komplett,
den ich hier habe. Guck mal,
der kann sogar verschiedene Farbton-Emojis.
Ja, das ist doch nice.
Kannst du Blackfacing
im Terminal machen, ja.
So.
Aber ist fast alles dabei. Sind Länderflaggen
dabei?
Länderflaggen? Haben wir Länderflaggen?
Länderflaggen
haben wir nicht, oder? Flags?
Ah, Moment, die stehen nicht auf der Hauptseite,
oder doch? Haben wir Länderfahnen?
Nein, Länderfahnen haben wir nicht.
Okay, Länderfahnen funktionieren nicht.
Okay, Länderfahnen
kann mein Emoji-Font nicht.
Was habe ich denn für ein
Emoji-Font?
Ähm.
TTF Joypixels.
Alternativ?
Ich glaube, der funktioniert im Terminal nicht.
Ich glaube, den hier. TTF Joypixels.
Ich überlege gerade, ob es vielleicht da eine neue
Version von gibt.
Joypixel.
Nein, gibt es nicht. Okay, also das Ding.
Ich glaube, man braucht
mittlerweile gar nichts mehr zusätzlich
großartig konfigurieren. Einfach den
Emoji-Font installieren
und gut ist. Ich glaube, der bringt
eine Font-Config mit, dass er funktioniert.
Ja, easy.
Aber leider keine Flaggen,
wie es aussieht.
Aber es wäre cool,
wenn der Emoji-Font wirklich einfach alles
könnte, aber der hat nicht alle drin.
Also die ganz neuen...
Aber guck mal, der hat sogar...
Ne, guck mal, die hat er nicht drin.
Die hat er nur zum Teil drin.
Er hat welche drin von 2020,
aber hat keine ganz neuen von
2021 drin und Flaggen hat er auch nicht.
Dafür hast du
Emoji in allen möglichen
Hauttönen
und ansonsten
alle Standard-Emojis. Ja, passt doch.
Ich würde sagen, damit kommt man eigentlich ganz gut aus.
Man muss nämlich gucken,
wenn man Emojis im Terminal haben will.
Man kann nicht...
Man kann nicht irgendwas nehmen.
Ist doch nur ein Hautton?
Nö.
Nicht nur ein Hautton.
Du hast die Emojis in schwarz,
du hast die Emojis in...
du hast die in dunkel,
brauner und zwei Weißtöne
und die Standard-Dinger in...
Ach ne, Moment. Ich bin...
Ich bin dumm. Das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Das...
Das kann der nicht. Okay, der kann das nicht.
Ihr habt recht. Das ist...
Das ist ja die Geschichte mit...
Wenn der Emoji-Font das kann,
dann gibt das hier eine weiße Hand
und das hier gibt eine schwarze Hand.
Okay, der Emoji-Font
kann das doch nicht.
Cut das mal.
Nope. Ne, guckt.
Das kann er nicht.
Wobei ich da gar nicht weiß, ob das an dem Emoji-Font
liegt, dass der das nicht kann.
Probieren wir es mal
im Chrome aus.
Es könnte auch einfach sein,
dass das ein Problem vom Terminal
ist. Doch.
Der Emoji-Font
kann das, weil Chrome verwendet
den ja auch. Das liegt jetzt am
Terminal, dass es das nicht kann.
Guck mal, und er kann sogar Länder flaggen.
Das Terminal hat damit irgendwelche
Probleme. Oder sind das
andere? Moment. Sind das andere Emojis als
im... Ne, ne. Das sind die schon hier.
Der Chrome verwendet nämlich den System-
Emoji-Font und der Firefox
Firefox bringt einen eigenen mit, deswegen
sehen die unterschiedlich aus. By the way, habe ich euch schon mal
gesagt, dass Emoji-Fonts und generell diese
wie das dargestellt wird,
ein absolutes Minenfeld ist.
Es ist total wir.
Es gibt wieder vier verschiedene Standards dafür
und blickt keiner durch.
Und die sind dann untereinander nicht
zueinander kompatibel. Vielleicht liegt es an
T-Max. Das könnte
sein. Aber dann sollte eher gar
nichts gehen. Das probieren wir mal aus. Emoji.
Ne.
Liegt nicht an T-Max.
Liegt vielleicht am Terminal.
Ich meine, wir können mal einen X-Term starten.
Der kann wahrscheinlich... Was zum Teufel ist das?
Nicht Boy. Wie heißt das Ding?
Ach, das ist dieser...
Das ist dieses Fake T-Max. Warum habe ich
das überhaupt installiert? Will ich
nicht.
Weg damit. Geht nicht,
weil... Break Dependency.
Ach, Hollywood
braucht das. Okay, dann kann ich's nicht
deinstallieren, weil wir wissen, dass Hollywood
auf jeden Fall
eines der wichtigsten Programme ist,
die man auf jedem Linux-System braucht.
Weil nur so kann man echter Hacker-Man sein.
Okay, dann muss ich das installiert lassen.
Geht nicht anders.
Seid ihr schon drin, Chat?
Wer ist schon drin?
Also ich bin schon lange
drin. Vor allem diese
komische World Map hier unten.
Sind auch drin.
Sehr gut. Ab wann zählt man
nicht mehr als Junior-Entwickler?
Boah, würd sagen zwei Jahre,
hä?
So eine genaue Definition gibt's da nicht.
Zwei Jahre Erfahrung, dann bist du eigentlich
kein Junior-Entwickler mehr.
Würde ich jetzt einfach mal so aus dem Bauch raus
sagen, ohne dass ich das jetzt irgendwie
belegen könnte oder
belastbare
Beweise, Erfahrungsberichte
dafür hätte.
Was bringt das Programm, außer gut auszusehen?
Nix, nix, nix. Aber es ist wichtig.
Für die
echten Hacker-Mans, die brauchen das.
Tja.
Ach guck mal, Firefox kann die allerneuesten Emojis
auch nicht.
Was soll denn bei diesen Emojis
eigentlich rauskommen, wenn's fertig ist?
Was sollen da sein?
Emoji 13.
Also ich vermute mal, dass das sowas wie
Gay Pride oder so ist.
Was gibt's denn?
Kappel
Man with Heart.
Das ist ein Zeichen.
Nee, oder?
Das ist aber das breiteste,
den breitesten Charakter, den ich je gesehen hab.
Okay, das kann das Terminal auch nicht.
Das Terminal ist nicht in der Lage, das richtig
anzuzeigen. Und das jetzt
auch alles noch in unterschiedlichen Skintones.
Gut ey, ich mein
Unicode ist groß. Da kannst du
im Prinzip noch alles reinpacken.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht...
Doch, das soll so aussehen.
Also die Aussage dahinter
versteh ich, aber die Emoji-Umsetzung
find ich...
uninspiriert
irgendwie.
Das sind einfach die normalen Emojis, nur
in einem Charakter.
Ah, Moment, Moment.
Die haben das alle bloß noch nicht implementiert.
Die haben das
alle nicht implementiert. Mein
Font zeigt das nur so an, weil
das noch kein extra Bild dafür hat.
So wird's dann später
mal aussehen. Okay, das ist was
anderes. Dann leuchtet mir das jetzt
auch ein. Weil ich wollt grad sagen, das ist
ultra uninspiriert. Da kann ich einfach vier Zeichen
hintereinander machen und gut ist.
Das ist was, da hab ich keine Schmerzen mit,
dass es das gibt. Ist doch eigentlich ganz...
Man hat so einen riesen
Unicode-Zeichen-Vorrat,
da kann man sowas auch reinmachen.
Wo man sich jetzt drüber streiten kann,
ist, braucht man das jetzt wirklich
in allen nur erdenklichen Varianten?
Wenn ihr mich fragt, ich war
ja persönlich ein Fan von, dass Emojis
gelb sind. Warum?
Weil das so eine abstrakte
Farbe ist. So sieht halt keiner
in echt aus, ne? Niemand hat so
eine Hautfarbe in echt.
Deswegen fand ich das eigentlich ganz cool,
dass einfach die Standard-Emojis und
auch die ganz viele Smiley-Filter
früher, dass das einfach gelb war.
Das war dann so quasi...
Konntest du im Prinzip
international verwenden
für alles. Danach hat man ja
gesagt, okay, die Chinesen...
Quatsch! Chat!
So sieht auch kein Chinese aus!
So ne...
So ne Hautfarbe hat schlicht und ergreifend
keiner. Außer vielleicht einer, der
irgendwie irgendeinen Ausschlag hat
oder so, ja?
So und deswegen fand ich das eigentlich ganz
cool. Man hat dann aber
das Fass aufgemacht und hat
quasi angefangen
die zusätzliche
Coats hinten
dran zu machen, dass die Emojis quasi
passende Hautfarbe haben. So und als man
damit angefangen hat, war klar, wenn
man jetzt neue Emojis einführt,
dann muss man die auch immer gleich in
fünf verschiedenen Hauttönen mit
einführen. Kann man machen, Unicode ist
groß genug, ist halt pain in the ass
für Leute, die das implementieren müssen.
Ich find's nicht schlimm, dass es das gibt, ich find's aber
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen unnötig. Ich finde,
im Internet können wir alle
gelb sein. Vollkommen in Ordnung.
Wir streiten uns schon oft
genug über irgendwelche unterschiedlichen Sachen.
Warum sind wir nicht im Internet einfach alle gelb?
Jemand mit kaputter Leber sieht so aus.
Ja, gut, kann ich nicht beurteilen,
aber das wäre doch schon äußerst
ungesund, wenn das so aussehen würde, oder?
So, wir sehen dann, okay, neue...
Jetzt muss ich grad mal gucken.
New Emojis.
Was kam da sonst noch so dabei?
Face Exhaling.
Sieht dann wie aus, so.
Moment, Joypixels
kann das angeblich, Face Exhaling.
Warum kann es mein Joypixels
nicht?
Mein Joypixels kann's Face Exhaling nicht.
Oder aber,
oder aber mein Terminal kann das nicht.
Das ist die große
Preisfrage.
Face Exhaling muss ich jetzt, muss ich
haben.
Face Exhaling kann mein, kann mein
Font nicht. Anzeige ist raus.
Angeblich kann
Joypixels,
kann das, warum, warum, warum kann das
mein Font nicht?
Scammed.
Was gibt's? Ich brauch einen anderen Font.
Font. Ich brauch einen neuen Emoji-Font.
Ich brauch einen, der Face Exhaling kann.
Leute, geht mir nicht. Chat,
Chat.
Regt euch ab.
Soll jeder denken, was er will. Wenn ihr was richtig
findet, okay. Ich ignoriere schon,
ich ignoriere Twitter schon.
Weil ich keinen Bock auf diese Diskussion hab.
Die hängen, die stehen mir echt.
Ich kann mir, ich hab absichtlich
mein Twitter auf Andorra gestellt.
Ich hab keinen Bock auf diese Diskussion.
Soll einfach jeder machen, was er will
und soll es nicht den anderen aufzwängen und gut ist.
Ähm.
Das geht nicht.
Das geht nämlich in, ähm, Terminal nicht.
Die kann man nicht im Terminal
verwenden, weil, wie gesagt, es gibt
vier verschiedene Implementierungen, wie man
Emoji-Fonts machen kann und
die sind nicht alle zueinander kompatibel und
das, die, das,
der Gnome
Terminal Font Renderer,
ich glaub wahrscheinlich ist es Pango,
der kann nur verschiedene, bestimmte
Formate und der kann beispielsweise nicht das
Google Format.
Das ist richtig Painschamp.
Es gibt, es gibt fünf verschiedene
Formate. Es gibt, es gibt ein Google Format,
ein Apple Format, ein Adobe Format
und ein Microsoft Format.
Passt mal auf, das ist richtig, äh, Painschamp.
Die könnten sich, die könnten
sich was vom USB-Forum angucken.
Äh, Twitter, nee, Twitter
hat einen eigenen Font, aber verwendet
einen Standard von einem der anderen beiden.
Ja, genau, so heißen
die Dinger. Also, es gibt
SVG in OpenType,
das kann nur Edge und Firefox.
Es gibt
Colorizipal, das können alle
Browser. Dann gibt's
SBX, das ist
Apple, glaube.
Und, ähm, dann gibt's noch
CBTD und
CBLC.
Edge kann alle,
ja, aber Edge, der Chrome Edge
nicht.
Tja, seht ihr mal, das ist wirklich
Pain in the Ass
Emoji Fonts.
So, und ich glaube,
dass das da nicht
im Gnome Terminal geht.
Also, die, die
Google, außerdem finde ich die Google Emojis nicht schön.
Leute, change my
mind, aber die Twitter Emojis sind die,
sind die optisch schönsten.
Die hier. Die Google mag
ich gar nicht. Google
Emojis gefallen mir persönlich überhaupt
nicht. Äh,
Microsoft finde ich auch dumm.
Und, äh, Apple
ist gut. Apple ist auch gut.
Also, Apple und Twitter. Ich muss
sagen, die Twitter Emojis gefallen mir am besten,
gefolgt von Apple.
Kann man sich drüber streiten, was schöner ist,
aber ich mag den, also mir gefallen
die Twitter Emojis am besten.
Das sind übrigens die gleichen, die man hier
auch in, äh,
FFZ, glaube, hat.
Also, hier im Chat.
Das sind, glaube ich, auch die Twitter Emojis.
Was ist das für ein Font?
Tweemoji.
Ja, ja, Twitter Emojis
sind das.
Also, Chat, was, was,
was, was, jetzt mal unabhängig davon,
ob ihr Apple-Fan oder nicht Apple-Fan
oder was auch immer seid. Welche sind euch
lieber? Also, wir haben zur Auswahl
Twitter, Apple,
Microsoft oder Google.
Microsoft?
Wirklich?
Okay.
Da sieht man mal, wie unterschiedlich der Geschmack ist, oder?
Microsoft sind am cleansten?
Ich mag die Microsoft
Emojis überhaupt gar nicht.
Apple.
Da sieht man mal, wie unterschiedlich
die Geschmäcker sind. Also, wir sind uns alle
einig, dass die Apple Emojis,
also, was heißt alle einig? Aber viele schreiben
Apple. Also,
ich glaube, die meisten mögen Apple
Emojis.
Bei mir ist es so, bei mir sind die auf dem zweiten Platz
und ich mag Twitter am meisten.
Vor allem, ich finde, ich finde den hier viel
besser als bei, bei,
also generell diese Sorte hier
viel, viel, viel
besser gemacht als bei Apple. Aber,
ja.
TTF-Tweemoji.
Ja, aber die gehen im Terminal nicht.
Die gehen im Terminal nicht.
Sonst hätte ich den schon.
Ich habe das vor einer ganzen
Weile mal durchprobiert und das einzige, was
funktioniert easy im Terminal ist, ähm,
Joypixels.
Oder Emoji One früher.
Was steht hier genau im Terminal?
No job support
Ernsthaft?
Warum entfernen die immer irgendwelche Features?
Ach ne, das geht um andere Sachen.
Die Blob-Emojis
mochte ich auch nicht. Also, ganz ehrlich, mir haben die
Google-Emojis noch nie gefallen.
Okay, hier steht, was die was können. Okay.
Siehste, Tweemoji ist
SVG und SVG
mein Pango kann?
Kann SVG?
Nein, Pango kann das, was
Freetype kann. Genau.
Und Firefox, und Firefox
kann, Firefox
ist, die haben zusätzlich noch die
Unterstützung dafür, genau.
In einer halben Stunde geht es um die Emojis, ja.
Ich würde ohne Scheiß, ich würde ultra gerne
die Twitter-Emojis im Terminal verwenden, aber es
funktioniert nicht. Ist halt echt doof,
ne? Hast keine Chance,
weil das kein SVG kann.
Es müsste halt einfach nur jemand, was heißt
einfach? Einfach nur sich jemand
hinsetzen. Moment.
Wait a minute,
geht das? Oder sind es die
schwarz-weißen? Moment, sind es die schwarz-weißen?
Was ist das?
Moment.
Wait a minute.
Geht das jetzt?
Okay, das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren.
Ich mach erstmal
einen Snapshot, bevor ich meine Font-Config
verhaue.
Moment, Moment mal. Snapshot, take Snapshot.
Excellent.
Jetzt, jetzt. Okay, wir installieren das
alte
Joypixel, ne, wie hieß das Ding?
Das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren.
Ich will Twitter-Emojis im Terminal
haben. Ja.
Joypixels,
weg damit.
Yes.
Hab ich irgendeine, eh, custom
Font-Config? Font-Config
oder so? Hab ich keine extra?
Keine extra Font-Config? Wo liegen
die Dinger da? ETC Font-Config?
Fonts?
Hab ich da irgendwelche
custom, customized
Dinger?
Ich hoffe nicht.
ETC
Grab,
äh, Joy.
Hab ich da irgendwas gemacht?
Alter, ich kann da mal tippen.
Ne, anscheinend nicht.
Okay, ähm,
dann installiere ich das Ding
jetzt mal. Also, was
muss man jetzt hier denn das da? Ja, ey, wenn ich,
das wäre doch mal richtig Poggers.
Twitter-Emojis im Terminal, da warte ich die ganze
Zeit schon drauf. Gib's mir.
Okay, to prevent
conflicts with other emoji
Fonts, das war beste,
das ist fast so gut wie der
Öttinger. To prevent
conflicts with other emoji Fonts.
Ist
not being automatically installed in ETC Fonts.
If you don't use
any emoji Fonts, simply
make a Sim-Link. Machen wir.
Bam.
Und jetzt müssen wir wahrscheinlich mal rebooten.
Sag bloß, das funktioniert. Ey,
das wäre Poggers, wenn ich jetzt Twitter-Emojis
hätte im Terminal.
Max, wann programmierst du endlich ein
Jailbreak für Tesla? Ist alles schon fertig.
Seitdem
ich mein Model S in der Garage stehen hab,
ist da natürlich Custom-Firmware geflasht.
Was meint ihr denn?
Meint ihr, ich fahr mein Auto mit Stock-Firmware?
Nie im Leben, Alter.
Achso,
Chat, wollen wir Prediction machen?
Wollen wir Prediction machen, ob's
geht? Mod-Check,
Mod-Check, Prediction. Gehen
die Twitter-Emojis im Terminal oder nicht?
Gehen Twitter-Emojis
im Terminal? Ja, nein.
Prediction.
Prediction started.
Können ja predikten.
Wir müssen ja ein paar neue Twitter, äh, äh,
Switch-Features, äh,
ausnutzen.
Okay, es ist ziemlich 50-50.
Es ist komplett 50-50,
mehr oder weniger, ja.
48, 52, 48.
Oh, what the fuck?
Jetzt ist es,
jetzt ist es instant geswitcht auf
Ja. Alles klar.
Jetzt ist 85%
Ja, 90% Ja.
Seid ihr euch da so sicher?
Es ist Linux.
Da geht eigentlich selten was auf
den ersten, okay.
89% meinen es geht, 11%
meinen nein. Okay.
Terminal.
Cat-Emoji.
Äh.
Moment, funktioniert das jetzt oder nicht?
Es funktioniert?
Es sind Twitter-Emojis
im Terminal. Das ist
ja ultra nice.
Das wollte ich schon immer haben.
Huge.
Gut, ich meine die Unicode-Dinger,
die das Terminal nicht richtig entschlüsseln kann,
passt, aber flaggen hat er auch
noch nicht.
Nice Twitter-Emojis
im Terminal. Jawoll.
Endlich.
Da warte
ich schon lange drauf.
Das Wichtigste. Jetzt kann ich endlich meine
Git-Commits auch ordentlich
mit Emojis ausstatten.
Jawoll.
Yes.
Exquisite.
Exquisitest.
Oder so haben wir letztens gelernt, heißt das.
Exquisite,
exquisite, exquisitest.
Ich kann das immer noch nicht.
Am exquisitesten.
Haben wir, haben wir extra
letztens nachgeguckt, wie man das
korrekt steigert, ja.
Ich bin
begeistert. Endlich Twitcher-Emo-
Twitch, äh nicht, was laber ich denn?
Twitter, man fängt das auch mit den gleichen
Buchstaben an.
Im Terminal, so ist das nice.
So mag ich das, gut.
Kann ich den Snapshot auch gleich wieder löschen?
Weil das hat ja alles funktioniert.
By the way, das ist der Grund,
was für vor allem eine Workstation spricht
versus
ähm, Player.
Snapshots sind viel zu geil das Feature.
Huge.
Ein
absolut massive Feature.
Bloß so, oh mein
zisch, nein.
Ich verwende zisch, also ich verwende
ZRSH,
ZShell, wie heißt das jetzt eigentlich?
Wie spricht man das eigentlich genau aus?
Ich schreib das immer nur. Ähm,
nein, verwende ich nicht.
Ich hab nur selbst ein bisschen Konfig rumgewurstet und fertig.
Ich hab eigentlich nur den Custom Prompt,
das war's.
GreatWilhelm, 6 Monate, dankeschön für den Sub.
Leute, ihr wisst, was
jetzt für eine Zeit ist, ne?
Ihr wisst, ihr wisst, was für eine Zeit ist, oder?
Ich geh jetzt pennen.
Ich glaub,
der Katz hat noch was zu fressen.
Ich mach noch ein bisschen Spiel-Action mit der Katz.
Reifenwechsel ist jetzt angesagt, genau.
Also, Chat.
Wir sehen uns, bis denn.
See you.